mes collègues après deux déplacements
très instructifs dans le département du
Rhône et puis hier à Bruxelles
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert par une table
ronde qui inaugure une nouvelle phase
des travaux de la mission davantage
tournée vers les producteurs
nous recevrons ainsi demain le directeur
général adjoint engie puis le président
directeur général de Total l'énergie
nous entendrons la semaine prochaine
EDF et Air Liquide mais c'est par la
filière agricole que nous entendons
cette nouvelle phase
mesdames et messieurs notre mission
d'information
je vais trop vite voilà il me semblait
bien
je voulais faire vite
nous avons ainsi le plaisir de recevoir
Monsieur luxe Messer je le prononce
correctement ça va bon ben
en principe on prononce pas le Z mais
bon les Français ont pris l'habitude de
le prononcer vice-président de la FNSEA
et président de la commission fiscale
sociale qui était accompagnée de
Monsieur Xavier Jamet
responsable des affaires publiques
monsieur Vincent Guyot juriste
fiskaliste monsieur Guillaume Chartier
membre du bureau de la Fédération
française des producteurs oléagineux et
de protéagineux qui est accompagnée par
Monsieur Claude soudé directeur adjoint
en charge du dossier biocarburant
monsieur Guillaume Annequin
administrateur de l'Association générale
des producteurs de blé et autres
céréales présidents de la FNSEA de la
Meuse qui est accompagnée de Madame
Lauriane chameau
responsable des affaires publiques de
cette association Monsieur Nicolas
yaland directeur général de la
Confédération générale des planteurs de
betteraves
monsieur Gildas Cotten responsable des
nouveaux débouchés à l'Association
générale des producteurs de maïs
voilà mais qui est accompagné de Madame
Alix d'amayé responsable des actions
régionales et institutionnelles de cette
association alors je précise que cette
réunion elle est captée et elle est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra ensuite
être consultée en vidéo à la demande et
ainsi sur Facebook et sur la queue
madame et Messieurs notre mission
d'information comprend des membres
issus des différentes commissions du
Sénat et qui représentent l'ensemble des
groupes politiques du Sénat
le développement des filières
biocarburants carburantes synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert représente un
enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais pas que
mais aussi pour la souveraineté la
compétitivité de notre économie la
France a développé une politique
ambitieuse en matière de biocarburant
qui a eu des effets
significatifs tant en termes de
production que d'incorporation de bio
des ailes et de bioéthanol dans les
carburants
ces orientations se trouvent aujourd'hui
contestée ou interrogés par la Cour des
comptes comme par des organisations non
gouvernementales l'organisation
Transport et Environnement que nous
avons additionné il y a deux semaines à
ainsi tenu un discours très critique sur
le bilan des biocarburants je ne doute
pas que ces analyses vont vous feront
réagir nous nous intéressons également à
la problématique des conflits d'usage
qui conduit notamment la Commission
européenne apprenez le développement de
biocarburant avancés plutôt que les
biocarburants de première génération
encore faut-il être capable de connecter
la biomasse nécessaire et
d'industrialiser la production
vous nous ferez part de votre vision de
la contribution possible des
biocarburants à la décarbonation des
transports je vous propose que chacun
d'entre vous puisse nous présenter dans
le cadre d'un propos liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes son analyse sur la
place des duocarburant comme débouchés
des différentes filières et sur les
différents enjeux que vous identifiez
notre rapport monsieur Vincent capo
canela vous a adressé un questionnaire
qui peut vous servir de guide mais vous
vous sentez libre d'introduire votre
propos introductif comme vous l'entendez
vous pourrez nous transmettre
ultérieurement les réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées
je passerai la suite ensuite la parole à
notre opérateur puis à l'ensemble de mes
collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions
en cours suivant l'heure nous changeons
de présidence puisque moi 18h je ne dois
me rendre à une autre réunion je propose
céder en premier lieu la parole à
Monsieur Luke Smet à air
le président de
de la capitale sociale vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
messieurs les sénateurs
ce rapporteur cher Pierre sur Stéphane
parce que Stéphane c'est un Picard et
puis c'est Monsieur Savary que avec
lequel on a bien travaillé sur les
retraites et on a encore beaucoup à
travailler et puis messieurs les
sénateurs que je suis pas mais que voilà
avec merci
je peux vous dire ça m'est très agréable
déjà je j'étais vice-président titre
mais comme la semaine dernière vous
savez pas c'est bien cette façon de
savoir qu'il y a des élections en ce
moment la FNSEA donc on a été réélu la
semaine dernière mais que l'élection se
fera le 13 avril donc on a une période
voilà où
j'étais bien président de la commission
fiscale et sociale je devrais être
renouvelé mais voilà on est à cette
période de flottement mais en fait ce
qui m'intéresse c'est d'être avec
l'ensemble des As associé
qui justement produisent
assez biocarburant et c'est en tout cas
je vous remercie de nous inviter
ensemble parce que je pense que c'est
important c'est justement d'avoir cette
vision et cette richesse de personnes
que j'ai autour de moi bien plus
compétente mais voilà qui permet en tout
cas au niveau de l'iPhone 7 faire une
transversalité vous dire que on avait au
niveau de la FNSEA a un rapport
d'orientation sur
issu sur le changement climatique en
2020 qui montrait justement tout ce que
l'agriculture je veux dire peu importe
comme solution il peut contribuer face
justement à ce changement climatique
comme
capacité à bien sûr à stocker de carbone
mais aussi à être solution sur beaucoup
d'éléments notamment par le biais de ces
90 000 exploitations qui aujourd'hui
produisent des biocarburants qui sont
une chance en tout cas pour justement
compléter et on l'a vu avec l'année 2020
22 sur lequel
pour arriver malheureusement avoir des
conflits aux portes de l'Europe pour se
rendre compte la nécessité de pouvoir
avoir la souveraineté alimentaire mais
aussi pouvoir être aussi source de
solution sur la partie énergétique et on
a bien vu beaucoup de Français à mettre
en place notamment des boîtiers pour
passer à le 85 le la chance aussi
d'avoir l'agriculture pour notamment
dans le cadre des transports et les et
bien merci à tous ce qui a déjà été fait
sur la capacité notamment via des
flottes captives de pouvoir faire aussi
et d'autres les filières reviendront
dessus bien sûr mais d'être capable
aussi de avec du Besson de de montrer la
capacité qu'à le monde agricole de
répondre à ces à ces enjeux de
décarbonation
je sais pas le sujet aujourd'hui mais on
est aussi en train de travailler aussi
sur une feuille de route à la
décarbonation de justement de
l'utilisation en termes d'énergie
puisque l'agricultrice est forcément
consommatrice d'énergie pour produire de
l'alimentation mais que c'est aussi un
enjeu pour nous important et je suis
j'ai été élu en 2011 et à la demande de
Xavier Belin et j'ai une pensée pour lui
et tous ceux qui ont travaillé dans ces
filières qui ont été assez novateurs
pour justement
CAPA passer justement parce qu'on passe
pas de la deuxième génération première
la génération 2e génération voir voilà
l'évolution et puis en tout cas quelque
chose qu'on veut saluer aussi justement
en termes de au niveau de la FNSEA c'est
tout ce que a apporté les biocarburants
en termes d'emploi en termes de
dynamique de filière avec des filières
quand même aboutis sur lequel on a une
capacité aujourd'hui et puis la capacité
aussi d'être moins dépendant notamment
grâce aux sous-produits que produit
grâce à ces biocarburants que sont bien
sûr la dépendance sur la protéine quand
on est passé de à peu près de 75% de de
dépendance sur le sur les protéines
aujourd'hui on est à moins de 50%, je
suis moi-même polyclicateur éleveur et
je peux vous dire que c'est d'utiliser
ton taux de colza aujourd'hui c'est
quand même des éléments intéressants en
termes de compétitivité de la ferme
France je suis aussi issu de du monde de
GT assez longtemps
administrateur de ma coopérative et
quand on a la capacité de pouvoir
produire et pour l'alimentaire et pour
aussi des filières énergétiques c'est
quand même un bouquet global qui permet
de d'aller justement sur la meilleure
valorisation auprès de nos agriculteurs
et nos adhérents donc c'est comme un
élément important
vous dire que c'est intéressant de nous
écouter aussi parce que voilà on a vite
fait de faire le grand tour en disant la
France si on reprend en arrière toujours
voilà sa vocation première c'est de
produire de l'alimentation bien sûr mais
historiquement il y a toujours une
partie qui a toujours servi justement à
la traction notamment
animale pour justement accompagner le
monde agricole et que aujourd'hui c'est
2% de la production qui est à
destination de ces carburant donc c'est
aussi remettre les choses bien à leur
place et je crois que on voit jamais en
tout cas c'est la volonté de la Finse
c'est bien amener l'ensemble de la le
sujet sur sa globalité de ce que ça
apporte en termes de dynamique de nos
territoires un peu partout en France ce
que ça amène bien sûr en terme d'emploi
mais ce que ça amène aussi tout le
travail qui a été fait par ces filières
et il reviendront dessus sur la façon de
produire aujourd'hui quand on produit
des des
c'était différentes
bibliocarburants il y a tout des
engagements de la part des producteurs
pour justement être l'optimisation des
intrants pour que justement on soit dans
les dans le dans une vocation la plus
durable possible et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'essentiel et durable sur
l'avenir de ces biocarbures
en tout cas nous on fait pas partie de
ceux qui se disent que voilà il faut
tout jeter mais que se dire que il y a
besoin d'accompagner et que il y a
surtout besoin justement d'entendre
point par point ce que chacun apporte et
la complémentarité entre ce que va
apporter la filière du blé du maïs de la
betterave et puis désolé au protéagineux
c'est bien dans sa globalité et puis de
justement tous les aménités positives
que peut apporter ces biocarburants donc
je serai pas plus long mais vous dire
qu'on est très attentif en tout cas
c'est un sujet important que on porte
sur ce sujet et puis à la fin je
ramenerai peut-être quelques éléments
complémentaires mais je pense que le
plus important c'est de laisser
justement c'est ces quatre filières
expliquer et vous apporter tous les
éléments de réponse à vos à vos
questionnements
c'est pas capter
je vais céder la parole à Monsieur
Guillaume Chartier membre du bureau de
la Fédération Française et producteur ou
léagineux et protéagineux monsieur
Chartier vous avez la parole en dizaine
de minutes
tant de développer très bien monsieur le
Président merci de votre convocation
monsieur le rapporteur capocanielas
ainsi que
vous tous représentant le Sénat ici
merci de nous recevoir sur ce sujet qui
est un sujet primordial pour nous et je
voudrais commencer mes propos
en précisant je dirais que la
trajectoire décidé au niveau de Red 3 au
niveau de
l'Europe
elle nécessite de mobiliser l'ensemble
des composantes du mix énergétique pour
pour atteindre son objectif 42,5% de
renouvelable en 2030
et donc mobilisé les contributions du
secteur agricole la première génération
la prise en compte des cultures
intermédiaires au titre des
biocarburants avancés notamment l'apport
des cultures intermédiaires pour
certains usages doit d'ailleurs être
consolidé
les carburants durables pour la
l'aviation notamment
prévoit que la première génération est
plafonnée à 7% de l'énergie consommée
par le transport ce niveau est
actuellement atteint en France et cette
contribution est essentielle dans la
décarbonation
les biocarbures première génération sont
aujourd'hui disponibles il existe la
production il existe les circuits de
distribution mais aussi la
transformation sans nécessiter de
nouveaux investissements aujourd'hui le
tissu au sein de nos territoires et bien
présent et est un maillon essentiel dans
la dynamique de nos territoires
au niveau de la décarbonation générique
la décoction générique peut-être
renforcée par la valorisation pratique
la valorisation des pratiques
améliorantes de la part des agriculteurs
luxemmer certes la spécifié tout à
l'heure l'aspect durabilité de nos
cultures n'est plus à démontrer elle est
allée vérifier au quotidien sur le
travail sur la traçabilité qui est faite
sur nos exploitations agricoles
ceci donc par rapport à par rapport à
l'ESCA par rapport à ce qui nous est
demandé au contraire on peut regretter
que les conditions de la concurrence sur
le marché nous est conduit à réduire nos
capacités de production qui ont laissé
la place à des importations
certes il y a eu des mesures antidoping
mais non non suffisante
même si nous nous félicitons donc de la
prise en compte par la France des
biocarburants produits
à base de soja et de palmes
l'agriculture est à même est à même
d'offrir des réponses à nombre de défis
notamment d'apporter sa contribution à
la décarbonation des transports par la
mise à disposition
de matière première valorisées en
biocarburant sans que cela ne crée
de conflits alimentaires ou non
alimentaires
pour le colza cette valorisation et même
nécessaire à la coproduction de tourteau
riche en protéines destinées à
l'alimentation du bétail
sans valorisation de la fraction huile
la graine ne serait pas valorisée et la
production de colza diminuerait sur sur
le territoire français
réduisant ainsi la diversité des
productions et nécessitant d'accroître
les importations de soja notamment
la valorisation de la coproduction
d'huile et de fait consubstantielle des
efforts en faveur de la souveraineté
protéique de la France les oléagineux
étant une source importante de matières
riches en protéines le tourteau
comprenant de 35 à 45% de protéines
les pyogrammes les biocarburants de ce
fait
à un équilibre économique global sur le
territoire
et dans les exploitations rappelons
d'ailleurs que par leur développement a
été
une réponse industrielle à une à une
condition de la mise en place de la PAC
aux jachères en ce temps dans les années
et que ce développement a contribué à la
mise en place d'une politique de
biocarburant afin de décarboner les
transports en Europe rappelons également
que les matières premières utilisées
pour la production d'objets au carburant
de première génération en Europe
répondent à des critères de durabilité
fixés par la réglementation
communautaire
au-delà des règles qui s'appliquent à la
production agricole en général
la conditionnalité et les éco-rogynes
ce sont les seules matières aujourd'hui
soumises à de tels critères
contenus de la réduction du plafond
première génération à 7%, les surfaces
consacrées au biocarburant ne
représentent aujourd'hui que quelques
pourcentages de la SAU surface agricole
utile mise en œuvre en France
le Bessan carburant à 100% base huile de
l'huile de colza
constituée aujourd'hui une réponse 100%
de renouvelable aux besoins de la
décarbonation du transport routier
en fait sur ces sur ces propos je veux
revenir sur sur le fait que
rien n'est antinomique entre alimentaire
et énergétique
au siècle passé l'attraction animale
c'était 30% des productions de nos
exploitations agricoles quand on regarde
nos livres et nos archives sur les
exploitations aujourd'hui on est qu'à
quelques pourcents de la production
agricole destinée à l'énergie et cette
production d'énergie elle est pas faite
dans le c'est à coproduit de la graine
ce n'est pas uniquement un produit c'est
un mix produit qui permet de faire de
l'énergie et à côté de faire du filtre
de la alimentation bétail ou d'autres
potes donc produits au niveau oléochimie
au niveau
pour remplacer la pétrochimie sur nos
exploitations agricoles aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas on n'est pas spécialisé
on peut pas faire du alors pour ma part
du colza sur colza oléagineux sur le
hallagineux on a une rotation c'est ce
qui amène aussi de maintenir cette
culture ce qui ramène une la
biodiversité ce qui ramène une rotation
un équilibre
au niveau maladie au niveau salissement
des terres aussi on a besoin de
conserver cette culture il est vraiment
primordial que le ce mix nécessaire sur
nos exploitations
on peut mettre en parallèle le mix
énergétique le besoin énergétique pour
se mouvoir pour le transport aujourd'hui
on n'est pas en opposition on est plutôt
en complémentarité avec d'autres
carburants d'autres
énergies qui pourraient venir et là tout
principal que l'on que l'on peut voir
aujourd'hui dans ces carburants de
première génération c'est effectivement
qu'on est là on est en place on maîtrise
le process on maîtrise le sourcing qui
est un sourcing local et il répond à un
besoin local aussi voilà pour
l'essentiel de propos et je reste à
votre disposition pour toute question
complémentaires
merci monsieur
on continue
donc je vais demander
je me trompe pas oui je vais demander à
Monsieur oui
Jean-Guillaume Annequin donc
administrateur de l'Association générale
des producteurs de blé et haute céréales
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président ce rapporteur messieurs les
députés
monsieur les sénateurs
c'est le stress de la première
en plus
voilà je suis agriculteur dans la Meuse
je suis administrateur à la GPB en
quelques mots la GPB donc c'est je pense
que vous connaissez mais c'est un mix de
50 % de représentant syndicaux du
territoire français plus un mix de d'à
peu près 50
50 acteurs économiques issus des os
organismes stockeur donc nous présentons
nous portons une représentons les
intérêts des producteurs français de
serrer la paille blayorge avoine seigle
sur vous
la France est le premier
pays en terme de production et
d'exportation européen de céréales
alors je vais vous faire un petit un
petit point sur le blé et la filière
biocarburant
producteur de blé ont contribué à la
création de la filière bioéthanol avec
le plan le plan biocarburant en 2000 en
2005 le blé et la première source de
bioethanol carburant française dit de
première génération avec un peu moins de
la production de la production française
de bioéthanol
quelques chiffres sans être voilà sans
tomber dans le dans le trop de chiffres
1,6 millions de tonnes de blés français
sont transformés pour le bioéthanol ça
représente 4 à 5% de la production de
blé tendre française
alors ça fait 230 000 hectares soit 0,8
% de la surface agricole utile française
alors je sais qu'on parle de surface
agricole utile souvent brut et net alors
pourquoi se distinguer brut et net et
c'est très important dans mon territoire
de polyculture élevage je suis
policulture
polyculturellever c'est que quand on
produit 1 kg de bioéthanol c'est en
moyenne 1,2 kg c'est les données de nos
commandes de nos interpro d'aliment
concentrés en protéines qui est vraiment
très important dans cette zone
intermédiaire je rappelle juste la zone
intermédiaire c'est 18 départements
c'est un croissant qui va te
Charente-Maritime à Lorraine c'est une
vaste une vaste étendue dans lequel on a
finalement un potentiel de production
moindre et on a un système de
polyculture élevage résilient qui
fonctionne très bien voilà et qui remis
un petit peu en cause quand on a voilà
une volatilité des cours et des intrants
voilà ça c'est important comme de
préciser dans cette filière carburant il
y a trois sites modernes de production
alors j'ai mis des centralisé parce que
je pense que c'est aussi important de
dire qu'il y en a un Lillebonne un bas
en cours pas en cours c'est écouter de
Reims et un en Alsace qui ont été
construits entre 2007 et 2008
Lille
vous présentez quelques atouts de notre
filière
filière qui présente
un atout mais que j'ai décliné en deux
on a mis à toute transition mais c'est
finalement transition sous deux sous
deux visions il y a transition en termes
de décarbonation et en termes bien sûr
environnementale c'est important
décarbonation développement de la
filière biarbiant répond à l'objectif
chiffré de décarbonation des transports
en 2030 en plaçant une partie de
l'essence en remplaçant une partie de
l'essence par du bioéthanol c'est la
principale alternative au carburant
fossile dans le secteur des transports
je pense que ce qui est important de
dire c'est qu'on est en 2023 et cet
horizon 2030 en terme de d'objectif
c'est c'est en fait c'est demain
et donc il y a quand même un sujet sur
le remplacement du parc automobile
et le fait d'avoir la possibilité de de
changer la motorisation notamment avec
ce petit module qui permet de passer une
voiture essence à une voiture
à notamment le 85 c'est un atout c'est
un atout majeur
il y a aussi bien sûr d'un point de vue
environnement on sait que le bioéthanol
émet 70% de moins de gaz à effet de
serre que l'essence
et d'un point de vue
décarbonations que je veux pas me
tromper alors je vais prendre ma feuille
mais
on sait une chose c'est que si on
combine intelligemment l'électricité
avec le bioéthanol on fera aussi bien en
termes d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre que les voitures 100% électrique
mais ça j'imagine que vous savez
peut-être déjà par contre ce qui est
pertinent à dire quand même c'est qu'on
a une étude
liften alors je sais pas si on dit peine
olive
iFPEN
c'est que quand vous fabriquez une
voiture 100% électrique
vous vous générez une émission alors de
mémoire ces quatre non pas de mémoire
c'est 85 g par kilomètre
et quand vous faites quand vous faites
rouler une voiture avec ce mix
énergétique vous générez une émission de
74 g de CO2 équivalent par kilomètre
voilà ça c'est une source
ifen et syndicat national du producteur
agricole d'alcool agricole voilà donc
c'est bien sûr enfin c'est la CV quoi
c'est l'analyse de vie de l'ensemble de
la de la voiture donc ça veut dire qu'on
a un impact positif sur le carburant et
aussi le véhicule qui va utiliser ce
carburant
d'un point de vue environnemental on a
alors je l'ai dit c'est 70%
de réduction de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport à l'essence et on a aussi
le sujet des particules fines c'est à
dire qu'on réduit de 90% l'émission de
particules fines voilà
l'autre atout c'est bien sûr un atout de
de
d'indépendance énergétique alors un
sujet qui essaie bien sûr amplifié suite
à au conflit russe ukrainien
le bioéthanol
issu du blé
consomme environ 3,2 millions de tonnes
de blé européen sur une sur une
production de 120 millions de tonnes la
France produit 600 000 mètres cubes de
bioéthanol soit environ ça fait 300000
tonnes équivalent pétrole c'est le
gradient énergétique et ça fait un
équivalent de consommation de 400 000
voitures ça c'est l'existant
un atout pour le monde agricole Dieu le
bioéthanol a permis aux agriculteurs de
diversifier le revenu en dehors des
filières traditionnels
il y a eu comme je l'ai dit dans les
trois sites que j'ai cités de réels
investissements de filières régionales
bâti efficace et performante
et comme j'ai comme j'ai un peu dit non
mais dans le début de mes propos c'est
un vrai un vrai intérêt dans cette zone
intermédiaire alors je vais parler un
petit peu de la Meuse parce que je sais
pas si vous le savez mais
dans mon département il y a 60% du bruit
de mots et fabriqué en Meuse et Meuse on
est quand même on est assez loin de moi
et dans ce cahier des charges on doit
utiliser 84% enfin 84% de la protéine
doit être issue du colza produit sur la
zone géographique ce qui veut dire c'est
que le début le débouché biocarburant se
prête parfaitement à cet équilibre entre
l'élevage et les pellicules la graine
par principalement pour faire du pur
carburant et on a le tourteau qui est
qui est valorisé alors dans nos dans nos
territoires où il y a de l'élevage ou où
il y a un réel besoin d'avoir ce système
résilient de polyculture élevage et ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne parfaitement
bien voilà
alors Luc l'a dit il y a aussi un aspect
emploi
j'espère que ce voilà que ces éléments
ont encore
raison d'un pays mais on génère 9000
emplois 9000 emplois directs indirects
induit équivalents et 9000 emplois n'ont
pas centralisé c'est bien décentralisé
dans nos dans nos dans nos régions dans
nos régions
alors Gilles est-ce que c'est là c'est
que je crois pas c'est pour la filière
éthanol
alors quelques enjeux très vite quelques
enjeux c'est que en fait on peut faire
plein de choses avec ce bioéthanol et
que on est quand même à la veille de
d'être en capacité
avec le voilà avec
l'investissement dans les dans les
nouvelles technologies émergentes de
produire du bioéthanol et du CO2 de
fermentation captée qui peut
certainement demain permettent de de
faire un carburant d'aviation durable
voilà les gros enjeux enfin ça c'est
voilà c'est vraiment une perspective qui
nécessite de l'investissement mais en
termes de durabilité
j'ai pas les chiffres en tête de
l'impact des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre des avions mais je pense qu'on
sait tous que c'est c'est plutôt très
important
voilà ensuite je terminerai je
terminerai je conclurai peut-être un peu
vite mes propos mais dire que la GPB
veille il y a deux points de vigilance
bien sûr la Stabil la stabilité
réglementaire et l'équité stabilité
réglementaire on a les accords
commerciaux comme le Mercosur qui
prévoit l'importation d'éthanol avec
comme vous le savez une concurrence
déloyale et des passes droites sur les
règles de production
et d'un autre côté on a
bien sûr un point de vue vigilance sur
cette sur cette volonté taxée les
biocarburants de première génération
comme des carburants fossiles et c'est
toujours voilà c'est toujours
un élément qui est qui est en discussion
voilà
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur
Nicolas
rialand directeur général de la
Confédération générale des planteurs de
betteraves vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président je suis rapporteur
madame la sénatrice monsieur le sénateur
et vous dire peut-être quelques mots sur
le l'implication de la filière betterave
sucre dans le la production de
bioéthanol
donc la filière betterave sucre
aujourd'hui c'est 400 000 hectares
cultivés en France par 23700
agriculteurs et la France est le premier
producteur européen de sucre
avec production annuelle de 5 millions
de tonnes et également produit à côté
façon produit pardon un côté 8 à 9
millions d'hectolitre d'alcool et de
bioéthanol puisque
l'alcool c'est un peu de molécule
plateforme dont on va pouvoir faire
selon sa qualité et bien du carburant
mais également de l'alcool pour
différents usages en chimie en pharmacie
en cosmétique en spiritueux et j'en
profite pour souligner que lors de début
de la crise covid en 2020 donc on a eu
des confinements qui ont conduit
évidemment à une baisse extrêmement
forte de la demande de carburant
puisqu'il était allé des déplacements
étaient très contraints et la filière
bioethanol à ce moment-là s'est mobilisé
très rapidement pour pouvoir utiliser
l'éthanol produit à des fins de
carburant initialement et bien pour
l'utiliser en alcool pharmaceutique et
donc pro la matière première pour
fabriquer des gels
hydroalcooliques ou des solutions et
donc contrairement à d'autres
équipements qui ont s'en souvient on
fait défaut et bien là on a pu compter
sur une filière locale qui a été très
réactive sur orienté sa production pour
pour répondre à un besoin qui était
évidemment extrêmement
urgent à l'époque d'ordre sanitaire
la production d'alcool et de bioéthanol
c'est une c'est une assez vieille
histoire en réalité pour la filière
betteravière puisque quand vous
produisez du sucre vous avez toujours
une partie qui n'est pas extractible et
qui va se retrouver dans la mélasse et
cette mélasse peut avoir différents
usages mais historiquement on la faisait
fermenter pour produire de l'alcool
et cet alcool avait déjà beaucoup
d'usages et c'est vrai que ça à partir
du début des années 90 et surtout avec
les années 2000 que la production
d'éthanol carburant s'est renforcé au
tout départ c'était pour
oxygéner les carburants les essences
réduire la pollution atmosphérique et
puis après est venue bien sûr avec le
protocole de Kyoto en particulier en 97
la thématique de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre dans les dans
les transports
et donc il y a toujours eu à côté des
sucreries des distillerie encore
aujourd'hui nous avons 20 sucreries 21
sucreries en France et on a 10
distillerie donc c'est une sucrerie sur
deux qui
à laquelle est un excès une distillerie
voilà un petit peu ce que ce que l'on
peut dire
deux autres éléments peut-être
historiques pour bien mettre en avant la
résilience enfin la contribution pardon
de la production de bioéthanol à la
résidence de la filière sucre le premier
élément c'est en 2006 une réforme de
l'OCM de l'organisation commune de
marché sucre et qui
conduit à réduire la production de sucre
sous quota en Europe de l'ordre de 10%
donc ça affecte quand même beaucoup de
pays
et comme cela était concomitant avec le
développement de la politique
biocarburant et bien dans notre filière
les deux coopératives que sont
cristallinion était Réau sont fait le
choix
d'investir massivement dans la
production de blocs de passer un peu à
une autre échelle en réponse d'ailleurs
à des plans gouvernementaux
et ça a eu pour effet et bien de limiter
la baisse des surfaces cultivées en
betterave ça les a stabilisés
c'est-à-dire que ce qui les betteraves
qui n'étaient plus cultivés pour faire
du sucre puisque la politique européenne
avait décidé de réduire cela et bien on
peut être affecté pour partie à la
production de bioéthanol pour autant
encore aujourd'hui ce ne sont que 10%
des betteraves cultivés qui sont
affectés à la production de bioéthanol
sachant que je le redis la seule totale
est de 400 000 hectares donc c'est une
part extrêmement modeste de des terres
que qu'on y consacre le deuxième élément
c'est pour illustrer la nécessité de
diversifier les débouchés pour toute
filière c'est le principe bien connu de
ne pas mettre tous ses œufs dans le même
panier et bien c'est vrai pour toutes
les filières je crois et c'est vrai pour
la nôtre je rappelle que les quotas
sucriers ont été
ont vu leur terme en 2017
cette fin des cottaï en coïncidait avec
une situation de surproduction mondiale
de sucre on a eu un effondrement des
prix et une crise économique qui a duré
trois à quatre ans
durant laquelle le Prix européen du
sucre était régulièrement inférieur au
coût de production alors que l'éthanol
lui
permettant encore c'était pas une
rentabilité extrêmement élevée mais il y
avait quand même une rentabilité et donc
ça a permis au groupe qui s'était
diversifié là-dedans durant cette
période de 2017 à 2020 mais j'allais
dire de se maintenir la tête hors de
l'eau et bien sûr ça a bénéficié aussi
aux producteurs aux agriculteurs
concernés puisque une partie du prix des
betteraves qui livraient leurs
industriels et bien leur valorisation
reposait sur sur une quote-part de vente
d'éthanol produit à partir de leur
betteraves donc c'est vraiment ce que je
veux souligner c'est l'imbrication très
étroite la complame la complémentarité
ça déjà été dit entre les productions en
fait le il faut percevoir ces filières
comme c'est le cas physiquement des
bureaux raffiner
à l'intérieur desquels la matière
première
ça va être des
cultures de production végétale et on va
avoir en sortie à travers différents
procédés une multitude de produits de
l'alimentation humaine de l'alimentation
animale et des produits pour toutes
sortes d'usages dans une complémentarité
qui fait que et bien chaque hectare
cultivé pour alimenter ses bureaux
raffineries on peut dire qu'il est
optimisé
sachant qu'il est cultivé dans des
conditions on ne le rappellera jamais
assez qui nous sont enviés partout dans
le monde
voilà ce que je pouvais dire en
introduction et on va
passer la parole à Monsieur Gilles la
scotten je reprécise que vous allez
responsable des nouveaux débouchés de
l'Association générale des producteurs
de maïs vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur madame la sénatrice
donc oui effectivement la GPN au class
l'Association générale des producteurs
de maïs
représentent évidemment les producteurs
de maïs dans toutes ses composantes je
dis bien dans toutes ses composantes
parce que il y a on connaît bien le maïs
le maïs doux en fait mais il y a aussi
donc on mange
dans les boîtes de conserve là par
exemple mais on a aussi donc le maïs
grain qui sert à énormément de monde
débouché sur l'alimentation animale soit
la midonnerie soit le plus carburant par
exemple
du maïs semences mais aussi le maïs
fourrage pour la production laitière au
globale sur à peu près un millier plus
de à peu près 3 millions d'hectares
un peu moins de la moitié pour le
maïssurage un peu moins la moitié pour
le maïs grain et puis voilà quelques
dizaines de milliers d'hectares pour le
maïs semences notamment nous sommes le
leader mondial à l'exportation
l'objectif de la GPM c'est que les
sculpteur physique correctement de leur
métier et donc on recherche en
permanence des possibilités de
valorisation de nos productions alors
pour ce qui est du donc du maïs grain la
production annuelle est en moyenne entre
12 et 14 millions de tonnes dans des
conditions normales la dernière récolte
n'était pas dans des conditions normales
on est aux alentours de 10 millions de
tonnes de production
sur à peu près donc vous me dit un
million 400 000 hectares de maïs gras
c'est la deuxième céréale de France
après le blé tendre
dans ces
usages il y a le bioéthanol depuis
2007-2008 également au travers d'une
usine neuve nouvelle qui a été
construite à lac sur un site en
réintustrialisation
dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques et pour
lesquelles donc une capacité de
production de 2 millions d'hectolitres a
été installé à partir de 500 000 tonnes
de maïs
c'est à peu près 4% du maïs français et
l'éthanol produit représente à peu près
20% de l'éthanol produit en France cette
activité
installée en 2008 et une activité
territoriale qui a une grande importance
puisque un peu comme pour le sucre il se
trouve qu'en 2006
les exportateurs du Sud-Ouest ont perdu
un marché amidonnier sur le Royaume-Uni
à peu près d'une même quantité et donc a
été remplacé substituée par cette
nouvelle activité qui a permis de
garantir donc une un
usage une utilisation locale de de maïs
ce maïs transformé en italhan produit
comme cela a déjà été cité à la fois
mais c'est bien de le répéter c'est
l'essence même de aussi de la bio
économie le avec le bioéthanol on
produit trois choses en fait à partir de
maïs du but éthanol 1 kg après
il a à peu près la même quantité de
drêches donc d'aliments qui aujourd'hui
sont utilisés par
le les élevages locaux et du CO2 et ce
CO2 biogénique donc peut servir à
d'autres usages mais je crois que vous
avez déjà entendu parler de ça
alors je voulais éventuellement juste
rappeler deux trois enfin sujet
complémentaire par rapport à ce qui a
été dit mais de l'accent en tout cas sur
certains d'entre eux l'un qui n'a pas
été abordé encore c'est la question de
la fiscalité
cette fiscalité qui
a accompagné le développement
développeurs et le même sénateur ou vous
savez combien chaque année en PLF c'est
un sujet qui est débattu régulièrement à
la fois sur le montant de la taxe la
TICPE d'accession d'énergie et sur la
taxe d'incorporation
tiroir aujourd'hui
cette fiscalité est amenée à évoluer
dans le temps d'ailleurs nous sommes
invités la semaine prochaine par la DGC
sur les réflexions qu'elle aurait sur
l'évolution de la tire verte donc
l'administration réfléchit à faire
évoluer les choses et surtout l'Union
européenne
a sur la table depuis deux ans une
révision un projet de révision de la
directive taxation des énergies qui nous
pose énormément de questions voir
d'inquiétude pour le résumer en quelques
mots simples la Commission propose
aujourd'hui de taxer demain le les
biocarbures de première génération de la
même catégorie que les carburants
fossiles
voilà si on peut résumer les choses de
façon aussi simple ce qui nous inquiète
énormément c'est que ça fait deux ans
qu'on en discute
et qu'on en est toujours au même niveau
d'ailleurs que même si la France nous
dit c'est compliqué etc enfin ce qu'on
peut retenir c'est que aujourd'hui la
France nous dit pas nous sommes contre
cette
cette manière de faire donc aujourd'hui
ce qui est sur la table c'est que les
biocarburants de première génération
sont toujours dans la catégorie
comprenant également les énergies
fossiles et qui seront donc taxés avec
le même minimum de fiscalité voilà ça
c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui nous
inquiète énormément et sur lesquels on
aimerait que la France puisse avoir une
voix un peu plus visible
là-dessus et puis
peut-être il y a eu des questions lors
des auditions précédentes notamment sur
les donc les visages des sols les
compétitions les compétition de l'usage
alors on peut peut-être appeler une fois
que Monsieur Michel de la déchaussé la
l'a dit la France a pris des mesures
pour
limiter l'utilisation de
matières premières à fort risque de
déforestation notamment à l'interdit le
palme et le soja et
ça ça va dans le sens de
d'une analyse faite par la Commission
européenne qui montre que finalement les
seules matières premières à fort risque
comme on l'appelle ce risque c'est c'est
le palme
et que les productions européennes les
matières premières européennes ne sont
pas dans cette catégorie
et ça il y a eu toute une analyse qui a
été faite on pourrait transmettre la
l'acte délégué en question et
deuxièmement on peut même ajouter que
dans le cas de la fixation de ce plafond
de 7% qui fixait notamment à encadrer
les risques liés à ces assez concurrence
d'usage soit vers alimentaire soit par
des fuites de carbone
la Commission s'est appuyée sur une
étude en 2014 en 2016 qui finalement
démontre aussi que si on est capable de
maîtriser les risques de enfin
finalement de limiter la déforestation
et
les les risques sur les tourbières puis
on diminue finalement le le
[Musique]
potentiel de fuite de carbone par
changement d'affilation des sols
indirecte à un niveau qui est quasiment
enfin négligeable de l'ordre de 4 g par
mega soul donc je sais pas si il va vous
parler mais en gros
les émissions de référence du
carbone fossile essence et gazole sont
fixés à 93 g et on va dire après par
rapport à cette référence on
n'empiocarburant réduisent les émissions
de l'ordre de 70%
voilà ce que je pouvais dire à ce niveau
là merci
merci
[Musique]
nous sommes dans les temples sur le
rapporteur
merci de vos interventions
je Vincent merci monsieur le Président
merci à chacun d'entre vous
nos interventions et de l'ensemble des
points que vous avez pu aborder qui sont
assez riches merci en particulier à la
FNSEA et
sensible au fait que vous veniez malgré
la période de renouvellement jamais la
plus simple pour pouvoir pouvoir
intervenir
monsieur Cotten à l'instant et puis
monsieur Annequin tout à l'heure ont
abordé un des points qui vous l'avez je
crois dit vous-même a été évoqué par
certains les intervenants dans d'autres
auditions
ça concerne les biocarbures de première
génération et un certain nombre de
critiques qui sont qui sont faites
ou parfois on les renvoie à
en gros des énergies fossiles pour dire
les choses vous l'avez dit vous-même
tout à l'heure et Monsieur Cotten à
l'instant et évoqué les discussions avec
la avec la commission avec européenne
sur la directive taxation des énergies
et le risque effectivement pour le coup
de les taxer comme tel bon si vous
deviez nous donner des éléments de
réponse des arguments puisque on est là
pour essayer de soupeser entre ce que ce
que nous entendons
et d'essayer toujours trouver le
contrepoint qu'est-ce que vous diriez de
synthétique de fort comme comme argument
en réponse à cela et puis ça m'amène à
vous demander
comment vous voyez la maturité des de la
deuxième génération deuxième génération
troisième génération on entend parfois
que y compris des chercheurs nous dire
que du point de vue
industriel comme du point de vue
économique
quand on passe à l'industrialisation on
a le sentiment que ça ça tourne beaucoup
moins bien
bon voilà et donc ça renvoie à ce que le
président vous a dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que on a entendu aussi en
audition à la Cour des comptes qui nous
a rappelé un rapport récent dans lequel
elle a tendance à questionner fortement
les blocs carburants notamment de la
première génération voir à suggérer que
c'est un peu derrière nous pardon de le
dire comme ça j'aime beaucoup la filière
agricole je lui donne des départements
urbain aujourd'hui on a tous des racines
rurales et mon père était ingénieur
agronome et j'aime beaucoup ce métier là
en tout cas tous ceux qui façonnent la
nature et qui produisent
donc
je suis obligé quand même de vous
envoyer des des tendres des perches pour
nous permettre d'avoir ce débat donc
voilà comment envoyer des choses et puis
dernier point sur la biomasse on nous a
parfois indiqué qu'il fallait réfléchir
à la structuration de la collecte de la
biomasse comment vous voyez ces points
là je veux pas être plus long parce que
il y a un certain nombre de collègues
qui pourront intervenir
je vais laisser mes collègues répondent
mais déjà je pense que le premier
argument c'est ce qui a été dit par
chacune des quatre as c'est bien la
complémentarité
du process et qu'à chaque fois c'est pas
la première vocation mais qu'à chaque
fois vous avez une sucrerie à côté il y
a une distillerie pour deux sucreries
que quand il y a le covid on était bien
content de trouver le gel
hydroalcoolique on peut parler du diesel
quand il a fallu dépolluer les côtes
suite à un naufrage on était bien
content de trouver du diesel pour venir
au karcher c'est à dire pour décoller le
mazout qui était sur les côtes bretonnes
et Loire-Atlantique sur on s'en souvient
parce qu'on a des fois je vous en
souvenez forcément c'est tous des
éléments qui voilà c'est des petits
détails mais qui amènent aussi et puis
par rapport à en tant que agriculteur ce
qui a été dit je suis aussi éleveur
aussi bien l'adresse
que le turto de ce colza et puis le
développement qui a sur les autres
productions parce qu'on peut parler de
tournesol aussi on a manqué de l'huile
de tournesol mais pour avoir de l'huile
de tournesol bah il faut avoir faire du
tournesol et les tournesol c'est bien
que une fois c'est selon les marchés ça
va être de l'huile mais ça peut être
aussi justement ce qu'on est capable
d'en faire et c'est vrai pour toutes les
productions quand il y a eu Lillebonne
on sait tous poser la question est-ce
qu'il fallait faire à Lillebonne une
usine d'éthanol quand on est à Rouen
premier port céréalier en Europe voilà à
destination du blé on est bien content
quand à Lillebonne on avait du blé qui
était pas forcément aux normes pour
aller partir pour faire du blé meunier
on était très contents en tant que
producteur de blé d'avoir et puis
l'adresse qui nous revient c'est à dire
que qui permet quand même de en terme de
compétitivité de maintenir des filières
aussi voilà et donc c'est bien dans ce
point de vue là je réponds pas forcément
en termes de mais c'est en tout cas la
vision globale puis après chaque filière
va bien bien sûr compléter mais ça
c'était un élément quand même que je
voulais
important et puis surtout c'est que
Paris c'est pas fait en un jour et que
pour avoir vu bien sûr pierre est un
défenseur Stéphanie pareil mais sur les
surtout le travail vous avez pu mesurer
l'évolution de la façon dont on produit
aujourd'hui ça a été dit par Guillaume
mais la traçabilité
l'issue de terre justement de sol non
labo qui sont pas issus de prairies
voilà etc pour que la durabilité tout
est tracé pour que justement on puisse
apporter les meilleurs garanties qu'on
est bien sur de l'optimisation d'un
tronc pour justement garantir la
durabilité parce que c'est aussi ces
éléments là qui sont aussi facteurs par
rapport à nos territoires il y a
l'emploi mais derrière l'emploi c'est
aussi la sécurisation de toutes ces
filières qui sont indispensables
aujourd'hui à l'ensemble de
l'agriculture française c'est-à-dire que
c'est parce que on a l'impression que
c'est voilà quand on parle de 500 même
pour le maïs parce que tu as dit sur la
partie à la Kaba mais c'est hyper
structurant sur la sur la partie
sud-ouest c'est à dire que quand on a ça
plus à côté les canards plus à côté
c'est des éléments qui d'ailleurs on a
structuré et c'est derrière un garant de
pouvoir justement quand on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire ça passe aussi
par ces éléments-là et puis je pense
qu'on est bien content aujourd'hui
d'avoir du B7 il y a même des fois on
dit bah demain on pourrait même encore
aller un peu plus loin avec le B30 qui
est normé au niveau européen
des fois on aurait tendance aussi un
niveau que la Commission européenne de
mettre plutôt des bâtons dans les roues
mais moi je pense qu'on a plutôt des
éléments pour que pour arriver justement
à la décarbonation d'aller justement sur
par échelon cranter les choses et
avancer avant d'avoir justement puisque
dans votre rapport vous êtes aussi sur
sur les différents sujets que sont aussi
demain tous les carburants synthétiques
mais on a surtout besoin aussi des
peut-être déjà de bien faire ce qu'on
fait et ce qu'on produit chez nous et
puis le dernier point que je voulais
apporter c'est que n'importe quoi ce
qu'on veut pas produire chez nous parce
que c'est c'est vrai qu'on a parlé de
déforestation on n'a pas d'autres
éléments mais on pourrait vite tendance
à avoir aussi avoir des choses à
apporter des choses sur lesquelles nous
en tout cas on a la traçabilité la
sécurité de ce qui est produit chez nous
ce chantier
oui simplement rajouter que sur le
le point du mix
le mix produit revenir vraiment on a
une destination alimentaire animale avec
le tourteau on a j'ai oublié de le style
de l'énoncer tout à l'heure en huile
l'huile alimentation humaine c'est 30%
du volume qui est produit aujourd'hui
les 70% d'huile qui restent aujourd'hui
on sait pas quoi en faire
si ce n'est deux incorporer en tant que
diester dans du carburant
au taux de 7 ou bien d'en faire du
Besson le Bessan c'est pas un carburant
de
je dirais c'est issu de matière
agricoles mais ça permet aujourd'hui de
rentrer un poids lourd en ZFE en zone
non faible émission donc on sait
répondre à la demande aujourd'hui
sociétal et à l'impact climatique en
disant on a des carburants on a des
choses qui existent déjà
on peut répondre de différentes manières
à ses besoins demain il y aura d'autres
carburants d'autres sources d'énergie
d'accord mais n'oublions pas que notre
base aujourd'hui elle vient elle vient
structurer et sa bien été dit
différentes filières qui ne sont pas que
définir énergétiques mais on a
absolument besoin de se déboucher pour
avoir un équilibre économique un
équilibre financier qui permette d'avoir
cette stabilité au sein de nos
territoires
voilà le point sur lequel je voulais
rappuyer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur pour répondre à votre
question aussi rappelée que les
biocarbures par construction
réglementaire aujourd'hui à minima
apporte une réduction de gaz à effet de
serre d'au moins 50 x 60 % en fonction
de l'âge des usines par rapport au
fossiles donc rien que pour ça ce n'est
pas du fossile c'est différent c'est
déjà un début de décarbonation parce
qu'on fait à B7 ça fait une réduction
plus faible au niveau du carburant mais
lorsqu'on est en baissant au minimum ça
veut dire qu'on a cette réduction par
rapport à un fossile ensuite cette
question de des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et quelque chose qui a été
prise en compte aussi par les
agriculteurs et par les filières et par
le développement des pratiques agricoles
qu'on met en oeuvre on peut conduire à
réduire encore plus ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
on peut aller jusqu'à 80 90% par des
pratiques utilisées par les agriculteurs
le nom labour l'apport d'une
fertilisation organique par exemple le
fait d'avoir des cultures intermédiaires
ce qui pratique haute participent aussi
de l'amélioration globale du
fonctionnement du système agricole et
un certain nombre de ces produits
clairement aujourd'hui sont nécessaires
à l'équilibre économique des
exploitations et elle est kimmiquent pas
seulement économique mais aussi
agronomique des exploitations ça permet
d'avoir une diversité de culture ça
permet d'avoir des rotations si on n'a
pas aujourd'hui doit aller à gineux
il faut faire autre chose à la place
quelque chose qui doit apporter une
rentabilité aussi merci
oui monsieur le Président très vite
parce que je vais reprendre un peu les
les éléments de de mon collègue mais il
est vrai que
on peut comprendre que la Cour des
comptes s'interroge mais je vais redire
ce que une source donc hyper
contexte les produits fossiles parce
qu'il polluent parce qu'ils émettent des
gaz à effet de serre on peut le
comprendre mais contact à la même
hauteur et je répète avec 70% de
réduction d'émissions le même les
carburants
issus de
issus des biocarburants voilà je
m'interroge en fait de la question
honnêtement je je bon peut-être que la
Cour des comptes a besoin de a besoin de
de générer des tailles je sais pas mais
en tout cas quand on peut pas mettre en
face un biocarburant qui réduit de 77%
les émissions et un carburant facile
rebondir enfin sur ce qu'a dit mon
collègue c'est vrai que nous
je rebondis sur cette zone intermédiaire
pour être agriculteur aujourd'hui vous
avez plusieurs valeurs sûres et il y en
a deux qui sont certaine c'est un le blé
de alors les oléopotagineux mais je veux
dire le colza parce que le tournesol
c'est encore pas trop maîtrisé voilà
donc
si vous avez pas de débouché garanti
pour ces deux cultures-là
derrière
un vous n'avez pas de filière vous
n'avez pas de débouché vous n'avez pas
de clients enfin voilà c'est ça peut
être très compliqué pour renouveler les
générations bien sûr enfin à très court
terme avoir une entreprise qui génère du
résultat et derrière trouver voilà
trouver des jeunes qui s'installent pour
avec avec un projet de un projet
agricole voilà ce que je voulais dire je
vais rester sur ces points là je vais
laisser Gilda parler de
du reste
alors peut-être quelques compléments
donc sur la G2 sur la maturité de la G2
donc ça c'est un sujet qui a été
travaillé
ce qui a été travaillé donc peut-être
que Monsieur
on l'a travaillé il y a pas eu de projet
qui a qui soit qui soit monté
il y a des enjeux qui qui sont nombreux
en général on imagine souvent utilisé
des résidus de culture donc pour le maïs
c'est des cannes de maïs ou de la paille
en se disant ben oui super je vais aller
disponible mais cette canne elle sert à
quelque chose elle remplit une fonction
avant avant qu'on pense à l'utiliser
pour l'énergie elle soit un résidu de
culture il tombe au sol et il nourrit
les sols entre guillemets en matière
organique donc il y a une fonction là
dessus d'ailleurs la directive de la
région renouvelable red 2 a mis en place
un critère poursuivre ça suffisant et ça
c'est déjà
une première un premier handicap par
rapport au à la production de
développeurs de seconde génération dans
un cycle agricole puisque il faut
choisir finalement est-ce que
j'extrais j'exporte en fait du carbone
qui va pas revenir directement sur le
sol seulement après il y a des
amendements on peut les rapporter donc
ça il y a
nous ce qu'on a ce qu'on a compris
étudié quand on a étudié cette question
là la disponibilité des résidus de
culture bon 1 évidemment elle est
conditionnée à aux surfaces cultivées
elle est quand même limitée à la déjà
des usages et les agriculteurs par
rapport à une propension enfin une
acceptabilité à exporter cette cette
ressource allez pas non plus totale
on sait bien que si je parle sur les
céréales à la paille il suffit qu'il y
ait comme l'année dernière un accident
de sécheresse et on va dire comment on
apporte de la paille aux éleveurs
les solutions techniques on trouve des
solutions techniques mais le package
complet de pour arriver à une matière
une ressource accessible pour les
biocarburants c'est c'est moi simple
oui merci monsieur le Président et moi
je voulais dire que pour la CGB
l'assimilation des biocarburants au
carburant fossiles relève de
l'aberration la plus totale moi ça fait
plus de 15 ans que je travaille dans le
secteur des biocarburants et ça fait 15
ans que ce débat sur la durabilité dure
donc c'est toujours une surprise quand
même de de constater que que qu'il est
encore vif je rappelle quand même que
les faits sont des tués il y a eu un
certain nombre d'études qui ont été
faites je parle de l'étude ADEME d'IRM
de 2002 l'ADEME 2010 sur l'Analyse de
Cycle de Vie des biocarburants donc tout
ça a été mesuré très précisément et des
conclusions étaient extrêmement claires
enfin en moyenne des biocarbures
produits en France à l'époque permettait
une réduction moyenne de l'ordre de 60%
des des gaz à effet de serre par rapport
au fossiles surtout le cycle de vie
depuis lors ça tombe d'investissements
ont été faits dans des usines pour avoir
des sources d'énergie renouvelables donc
décarbonées en partie au moins les
processus que ce soit par de la
géothermie profonde par de la biomasse
il y a la captation du CO2 fermentaire
sur certains sites de production de
bioethanol donc les choses n'ont fait
que s'améliorer
chaque lot de biocarburant qui est
incorporé en Europe circule avec son
passeport de durabilité
c'est pas un passeport qu'on délivre
comme ça tout ça est calculé et donc on
a l'eau par l'eau le pourcentage de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport au fossiles sachant que il y a
une limite il y a un plancher
réglementaire qui est 50%.
alors reste le débat sur les changements
indirects d'affectation des sols qui qui
lui aussi a été vif il y a quelques
années Gilles dakotaine l'a dit la
Commission européenne s'est penche à
maintes reprises sur le sujet un acte
délégué par en 2019 qui dit les choses
très clairement les changements
indirects d'affectation des sols et donc
le comment dire le surplus des missions
de gaz à effet de serre qui ne seraient
pas comptabilisées il a imputable
essentiellement à des matières premières
qui ne sont pas produites en Europe
et donc et en particulier
l'huile de palme donc je pense qu'à un
moment il faut mettre un terme à ce
débat là et constater qu'encore en 2023
on en est à vouloir assimiler les
biocarburants qui ont quand même permis
de décarboner assez significativement
les transports ces 20 dernières années
maintenant à des fossiles c'est
absolument incompréhensible et
totalement injustifié enfin c'est la
même commission européenne qui a mis en
place un certain nombre de garde-fous de
garanties de dura de critères de
durabilité qui aujourd'hui en fait se
décrédibiliserait en disant finalement
ce qu'on a mis en place
ne vaut rien alors que les opérateurs
tous les OP des filières connaissent
toute la valeur de de cette
certification de durabilité
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
là-dessus et donc nous on a toujours dit
c'est pas les biocarbures de première
génération qui sont bons ou mauvais il
faut faire le distinguer par matière
première sur les conditions de
production de cette matière première et
l'origine géographique c'est ça le qu'il
faut regarder c'est pas un grand tout
totalement uniforme donc là il faut
vraiment y mettre beaucoup de d'oignons
sur la deuxième génération
j'allais dire de la même façon ça fait
15 ans que le débat est ouvert première
génération deuxième etc et 15 ans après
où en est-on et bien on a toujours pas
un site en France et on en a peut-être
un ou deux sites pilotes dans l'Union
européenne qui font de la deuxième
génération donc pourquoi bah ça c'est
une preuve me semble-t-il éclatante que
ça ne fonctionne pas comme on aurait
voulu et les raisons finalement
on peut les identifier assez simplement
certaines ont été évoqués il y a un
énorme sujet en effet de disponibilité
de mobilisation de biomasse il n'y a pas
de réserves cachettes biomasse qu'on
pourrait mobiliser facilement et
acheminer sur un site sachant que des
usines de biocarburant
ce sont pas des micros usines vous allez
sortir
de trois deux trois fûts de carburant on
parle de de centaines de milliers de
tonnes et donc comme avec la deuxième
génération on est plus sur les organes
de réserve mais sur de la biomasse un
peu générique ça peut être des résidus
des déchets de la plaquette de bois des
cultures biomass dédiées les rendements
sont moins bons donc ça veut dire que
pour produire la même quantité de
biocarburant la quantité en amont de
biomasse est mobilisée colossale donc ça
c'est un premier frein logistique
économique le deuxième frein mais il est
en partie levée aujourd'hui il était
technologique c'est à dire
effectivement mettre au point le procédé
donc ça c'est à peu près le cas au moins
à l'échelle labo ou pilote c'est vrai
que passer à l'échelle industrielle ne
donne pas toujours les les résultats
escomptés et puis le dernier point il
est tout simplement économique c'est que
ces procédés sont beaucoup plus
complexes ils sont plus coûteux
doublement lors de l'investissement et
en coût de production et donc lorsque on
comme la fin un peu la Commission
européenne vous laissez une place
effectivement à des biocarbures avancés
mais les biocarbures avancés c'est
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais un
fourre-tout ou le jeu de la concurrence
est faussé parce que vous allez pouvoir
à travers des procédés utilisés c'est
une liste de matières premières
on parle pas de procédé quand on définit
au sens réglementaire européen des
biocarburants avancés donc là c'est le
que le meilleur gagne quoi et et il n'y
a pas de place pour ce qu'on appelait en
tout cas il y a quelques années
véritablement la deuxième génération
voilà un petit peu les principales
raisons pour lesquelles effectivement ça
ne ça ne bouge pas tellement
merci Pierre oui merci président
monsieur le rapporteur dites-moi
quelques questions en fait que je que
vous connaissez tous c'est les critiques
qui peuvent se porter sur le
développement des biocarburants de
première génération depuis leur création
cette critique
[Musique]
sur la disponibilité des sols entre
alimentaire d'un alimentaire ma question
pose sur le taux d'incorporation maximum
que l'on pourrait justement accéder
disponibilités des sols mettre à
disposition
première question ensuite est-ce qu'il y
a un impact sur le prix du foncier
agricole le fait de faire parce que on
entend ce genre de question sur le prix
du foncier parce que on va faire du
bio-carburant on va faire de la
métallisation etc et ça peut surencher
déséquilibré les prix de marché
à Guillaume Chartier j'aurais voulu
connaître le taux de dépendance
protéines en France et en Europe
je réussis souhaité et connaître les
montants des énergies consommées par
rapport aux énergies produites matières
premières par matière première
production par production éthanol
biodiesel
ensuite sur la taxation et sur le gaz
est-ce que la taxation par contre des
biocarburants donc et de toutes les
énergies renouvelables seraient calées
aussi sur la taxation du des produits
pétroliers
c'est une question
et est-ce que la taille des outils
industriels qui a été élaboré au début
des biocarburants aujourd'hui laisse une
disponibilité et quelle disponibilités
en matière de production donc de surface
donc de taux d'incorporation je reviens
à ma première question
[Musique]
que dans le nord de la France ce débat a
lieu bon et
apparemment ils partagent les
agriculteurs
certains sont sûrs une tendance de dire
nous sommes là pour faire de la culture
vivrière et d'autres disent ben non tant
qu'à faire on a qu'à intercalé de temps
en temps de la culture qui ira
directement
à la production de biocarbures donc je
voudrais savoir un petit peu je sais pas
qui ça s'adresse mais quel est votre
position sur cette question là parce que
ça une importance sur le développement
de des biocarburants merci
oui merci moi je suis dans un
département à la Marne on se pose pas de
style de questions parce qu'on a un
certain nombre d'usines on investit je
suis quand même étonné depuis 20 ans que
ça fait 20 ans que je suis là dedans
encore que il y a cette concurrence
entre l'alimentaire leumentaire et
penser à une fiscalité
identique entre le carburant entre les
biocarburants et
le pétrole ça vient peut-être aussi on a
une part de responsabilité je pense et
même au niveau de cette commission vous
voyez c'est une commission autour des
biocarbures or on voit bien les filières
c'est un coproduit c'est le principe de
la bio raffinerie végétale et
biocarbonate c'est un coproduit quoi on
peut pas traiter ça le bioéthanol ou
bien du du Esther on peut pas le traiter
simplement au sein d'une vision
strictement carburant
ou énergie quand on parle d'électricité
électricité c'est de l'énergie que
j'aurais du pétrole c'est de l'énergie
elle est biocarburants c'est pas que
c'est une filière complète donc quand on
se permet de critiquer le biocarburant
ça veut dire que on critique toute la
filière agricole parce que on ne pense
pas ceux qui sont spécialisés biocars ou
énergie ils sont pas du tout
attentifs au reste des coproduits qui
sont généralisés donc je pense qu'il
faut que dans notre rapport on soit
attentif à cela qu'il y a une part très
particulière par rapport aux autres
sources d'énergie me semble-t-il je me
permets en tout cas de faire cette
remarque mille excuses de mon
impertinence mais j'y suis attaché quand
même une question
simple également comment ça se fait que
on n'a pas pu jouer un rôle plus
important par rapport aux véhicules
automobiles où on est parti comme ça
tout énergie en 2035 toute énergie tout
électrique en 2035 alors que je suis
personnellement et
avec d'autres intimement persuadés que
pendant un certain nombre d'années on
peut encore rentabiliser les équipements
qu'on a fait quand on voit les
rendements par rapport à ça faut arrêter
de de mettre tous ses œufs dans le même
panier quoi on verra maintenant on
commence une marche arrière etc donc il
y a vraiment de la place pour ça parce
que véhicule le plus écolo c'est
l'hybride libides biocarburant et
électrique quand même donc il faut il y
a une vraie place à jouer dans
l'aviation les moteurs me semble-t-il
mais toi tu connais encore mieux le
sujet que moi mais il me semble que les
moteurs d'avions incorporent encore
mieux les biocarburants que les moteurs
de voiture et puis une dernière petite
question comment ça se fait que votre
acteur il roule pas quand même au
biocarburant quoi parce que là quand on
compare effectivement la mobilité dans
les dans les structures agricoles et on
pense au cheval qui était l'élément
tracteur que vous nourricier que vous
abattiez etc il y avait un vrai circuit
court quoi donc on pourrait penser
également que le tracteur
la simplifierait s'il mettait du
biocarburant le mettre du fioul quoi
alors pourquoi ça n'avance pas cette
affaire là
merci monsieur le Président moi je suis
comme mon voisin de droite je suis Farid
et des débats répétitifs qu'on peut
avoir et c'est justification permanente
qu'on sollicite auprès de vous quant à
la qualité intrinsèque des biocarburant
enfin créer le groupe d'études il y a 20
ans l'Assemblée nationale et on avait
déjà en impayés plus que ça merci donc
voilà je voudrais poser une question
spécifique à la GPB je regardais le le
cours du du blé
par boisseau qui qui atteint aujourd'hui
des sommets assez impressionnants au
regard du contexte géo-politique que
nous vivons je crois qu'on c'est le plus
haut cours depuis 20 ans ou 25 ans et
donc ma question est la suivante est-ce
que cette
ce contexte géopolitique a influer sur
les masses que vous mettez dans le dans
le bio carburant dans le bioéthanol
parce que le problème qu'on a toujours
eu quand on parle du biocarburant et
notamment avec le blé c'est tout
l'aspect symbolique qu'il y a autour de
la nourriture qu'on n'a pas avec la CGB
et quand on travaille avec les
betteraviers on n'a pas ce même ce même
problème d'image mais moi quand je
tournais un petit peu quand on a lancé
le groupe d'études à l'Assemblée en 2002
et je tourne en France pour parler
biocarburant parfois on était mal
accueilli parce qu'effectivement on
avait des pancartes sous on mettait le
blé dans le réservoir quoi et à côté il
y avait des photos de gens affamés et
donc bon voilà alors pourquoi je parle
de ça parce que est-ce que le fait que
les cours soient aujourd'hui aussi haut
fait que vous ne vous interrogez pas sur
donc une réorientation de vos masses
merci est-ce que il y a Gérard Elec
est-ce que nos deux collègues veulent
poser de questions bon alors Gérard tu
as la parole
merci monsieur le Président merci à vous
de nous avoir éclairé et de m'avoir
instruit
notamment sur tous les champs du
possible si je puis dire alors moi je
viens d'une petite région agricole qui
s'appelle la Bretagne
et d'un petit département qui s'appelle
les Côtes d'Armor qui est le plus petit
le moins peuplé
et je suis
issu du monde agricole
j'utilise un dessin d'ailleurs le terme
issu
je ne suis pas sorti quand on est sorti
parfois on ne rentre pas
quand on est issu de ce monde là on en
est jamais complètement sorti c'est
peut-être de la sémantique mais ça me
paraît important et nous sommes malgré
tout un département et une région où
nous sommes véritablement
des régions une région à vocation
agricole je rappelle pour juste un
chiffre
ce secteur primaire emploie à peu près
70 000 personnes encore en mode c'est
dire combien
ce secteur agricole notamment et
agroalimentaire est un secteur
déterminant pour nous
et il se trouve que
travaillant assez régulièrement avec la
chambre nous avons relevé il y a de cela
quelques semaines déjà que la production
laitière dans notre département
avait chuté de 10 millions de litres en
un an
10 millions de litres c'est la moitié de
la production du département de l'Eure
donc c'est quelque chose de d'assez
substantiel quand même
tentez si bien que la tentation est
grande de vouloir faire autre chose que
du lait
je le dis comme ça
avec des effets derrière qui sont assez
inquiétant
par exemple la Végéta végétalisation des
terres qui se développent et c'est pas
tout à fait fait pour ça dans nos
régions
l'autre jour j'étais avec cinq
exploitants agricoles de belles
exploitations laitières performantes
il se posait la question de la
méthanisation sauf qu'en se mettant à 5
dans une unité de méthanisation
ils entraient dans la séquence de
production de méthane qui s'apparentait
beaucoup
à une unité de production industrielle
et c'est pas leur job donc à ce jour le
projet initial tel qu'il avait envisagé
il devient caduque voilà vous voyez le
et ça me conduit évidemment à me référer
à ma modeste expérience
du petit paysan que je suis j'aurais
bien sur l'exemple que c'était mon
collègue ça varie à l'instant
il est vrai que du temps où le tracteur
est-elle cheval on ensemençait quelques
hectares de trèfles violets et c'était
de l'énergie pour l'attraction
et la ferme il trouvait un peu de
résilience
il se trouve aussi qu'on entretenait les
fonds de vallées etc c'est assez ringard
ce que je dis je vous le conseille mais
enfin faudra bien qu'on s'en occupe un
jour
on faisait du bois ça veut pas dire
qu'on était devenu des producteurs
d'énergie on en faisait pour nous-mêmes
et on en vendait un peu ça donnait un
peu de résilience à la ferme pour les
plus courageux qui s'avaient ramasser
les pommes il produisait aussi un petit
peu de voilà ça veut pas dire qu'ils
étaient devenus des producteurs de
spiritueux mais ça donnait un peu de
résilience donc ça me conduit à me poser
dans les conditions de notre temps une
question de fond qui est la suivante
c'est comment
ces effets résilients vont profiter à la
production
je considère que nous sommes confrontés
à un vrai problème de fond c'est un
sujet plutôt agricole qu'il faudrait
qu'on évoque sûrement dans d'autres
lieux mais c'est la question du retour
de la valeur ajoutée à la ferme je pense
que c'est une question centrale et il me
semble que
il faudrait il serait bien que l'on
puisse aborder cette question du retour
de la valeur ajoutée à la ferme si on
veut parler développement durable et ça
ne remet nullement cause la qualité des
exposés qui nous ont été faits mais
voilà mon questionnement qui est peu
paraît de décalé par rapport à la à
l'exposé qui a été fait mais écoutez je
profite de l'occasion de votre présence
pour que vous éclairiez un peu mon
esprit sur le sujet merci si Gérard je
vais avant de vous passer la parole je
vais demander à notre rapporteur de la
dernière qui est pas de quiproquos sur
la mission qu'on est en train de faire
au Sénat oui merci président alors c'est
vrai qu'avec le président
rapporteur je suis garant de l’écuité de
quitter les débats et je pense que si
vous recevons je ne vous mentionnez pas
ce que nous avons entendu et qui est
public d'ailleurs dans les autres
auditions vous seriez en droit de me
dire tiens c'était sympa on a bultet on
est reparti et vous avez pas abordé les
sujets qui fâchent donc mon devoir est
de vous poser les questions sur les
sujets qui fâchent parce que d'autres
les exprimes et les meilleurs
ceux qui sont plus en capacité
d'apporter les bonnes réponses c'est
quand même vous donc légitime que voilà
qu'on qu'on vous pose des questions et
c'est vrai que mais vous l'avez fait
tout à l'heure les uns les autres je
pense qu'il faut muscler l'argumentaire
sur la réponse strictement
environnementale parce que la vision
globale vous l'avez très bien défendue
et j'ai envie de dire que au Sénat on la
partage mais la question qui est posée
c'est que la France se met en situation
d'avoir des réponses à une problématique
strictement environ mentale une
problématique de décarbonation et qu'il
y a donc un raisonnement multicritaire
sur des questions d'efficacité
d'efficacité énergétique
environnementale et ça vient percuter
euh
la vision plus globale que que vous
défendez que nous partageons voilà donc
il faut avoir ça en tête il fait il faut
vraiment je pense que vous nous
apportiez des éléments claire là-dessus
vous avez commencé à le faire on verra
peut-être mieux question simplement
c'est alors pour être plus positif il y
a des besoins vous l'avez dit peut-être
sur l'automobile sur l'aérien sur le
maritime sur le fluvial comment vous
voyez la capacité de la filière à
répondre à ses besoins là à peut-être se
réorienter vers ce type de réponse et
puis également vous avez dit aussi que
on importe
parfois depuis des pays extérieurs à
l'Union européenne voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez produire plus
là-dessus est-ce que vous avez aussi
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une capacité
d'export de notre côté et enfin les
soutiens que vous avez aujourd'hui et
pour les besoins d'investissement
notamment voilà est-ce que
l'accompagnement pourrait être amélioré
votre point de vue comment parce que ça
fait partie des questions qui se qui se
dessinent aussi au niveau de l'Union
européenne
merci donc c'est tout le problème de la
ressource
je veux bien commencer à essayer puis
sachant que bien sûr mes collègues vont
compléter je remercie pour toutes les
interventions il faudrait faudrait plus
qu'une journée en passant par la
Bretagne passant par le Grand Est
Picardie excusez-moi le vauclus c'est ça
voilà donc mais c'est très enrichissant
et je pense que si ça fait 20 ans qu'on
se pose la question c'est peut-être
qu'on est pas assez bon dans
l'argumentaire mais c'est surtout c'est
qu'il y a des on a des tracteurs qui
sont peut-être plus costauds que nous en
communication et que si ça veut dire
qu'on dérange quand même je me souviens
du débat qui a eu à la mettre quand
total voulait et qu'on a la arraché 10%
à l'époque mais aujourd'hui plus que ça
de biocarburant c'est parce que
forcément ça gênait je vois
qu'aujourd'hui on a un partenariat à
l'effet de cela avec total cela
décarbonation ce qu'on doit pas être si
mauvais avec ça et c'est qu'on est
capable justement de tracer du carbone
durable et de fixer du carbone je crois
que quand on parle mécanisation
la semaine dernière christiane a eu la
même question en huis clos à la FNSEA je
vais pas trahir le huis clos en disant
est-ce que on produit de l'énergie ou de
l'alimentation quelle est la vision de
la FNSEA christiane a dit
ça y est j'ai travaillé
c'est pas grave c'est pas le rapport
encore qui et donc là sa réponse a été
assez claire c'est de dire bien sûr
notre première mission c'est de produire
l'alimentation mais sur produire en même
temps de l'énergie ou si on peut avoir
une économie circulaire à côté on aurait
on serait trop bête de pas de pas le
faire et je crois que le bon sens de la
Marne c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui on a quand même une
réglementation française notamment sur
la sur les agriculteurs principales avec
à limiter à 15% et que quand aujourd'hui
on peut avec une culture complémentaire
de trois cultures en deux ans être
capable de produire tout en maintenant
la richesse du sol voire en captant
encore plus de sol avec comme qui a été
dit les pratiques culturelles du nom
labour et autres qui fait que on a un
bilan carbone qui s'améliore la capacité
à une économie circulaire quand on
produit du méthane on produit aussi du
digestack qui fait qu'aujourd'hui moi je
vois bien que beaucoup quand on voit le
prix des engrais aujourd'hui quoi doublé
au triplés si on peut être autonome sur
la partie fertilisation sur la partie
haute c'est quand même pas si mal que ça
quand on est autonome tout à l'heure on
se parti circulaire quand sur mon
élevage je produis du colza mais en même
temps je produis deux tourteau de colza
quand je produis de la betterave du
sucre je produis aussi de la pulpe mais
en partie ces éléments je peux faire
pareil avec le maïs et je peux faire
pareil avec le blé donc je me dis c'est
pas si mal que ça quand on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire ça commence
déjà par être capable de d'être moins
dépendant et ça je pense que c'est une
bonne chose sur la méthanisation je
pense que on l'a bien vu quand on voit
qu'on est en train de fermer les dialy
circuits qui nous approvisionnés en gaz
on était tout content de se dire que
finalement
qu'on peut en produire un peu de façon
durable chez nous ça peut être une
solution faut éviter les les conflits
d'usage et moi je l'entend aussi dans
les différentes régions c'est que si oui
demain on se bat entre le méthaniseur et
puis l'éleveur pour la pulpe là ça pose
question mais je pense qu'on est assez
intelligent pour se mettre d'accord et
la même chose sur d'autres coproduits ou
ce produit et puis sur les biocarburants
là où on n'est pas bon c'est que et vous
l'avez certainement fait mais quand on
va sur un site de production notamment
de diester vous allez à Compiègne mais
vous voyez pas la chimie grâce qui a été
développée grâce parce qu'à côté on
faisait on faisait des biocarbures mais
à côté la chimie verte aujourd'hui le
votre peinture qu'on va mettre sur qu'on
va mettre dans mais elle est issue de la
et aujourd'hui il se battent pour que
justement on soit à 100% mais grâce
justement à cette matière première qui
est à la base de donc je pense que c'est
quand même des éléments qui sont plutôt
structuants monsieur le rapporter à le
Président je veux vous allez céder la
place parce que vous avez une autre
étude mais ce qui est important c'est
une stabilité réglementaire et je pense
que ce qu'on a surtout besoin que nos
filières ont besoin et c'est justement
c'est pas d'être de détracteur mais
c'est des des personnes qui nous
contribuent à améliorer parce que on est
même si on n'est pas passé au carburant
de deuxième génération quand on voit
l'amélioration de toutes ces filières
depuis 20 ans je pense que c'est la
meilleure aussi réponse et je pense
qu'on a certainement à vous amener dans
les prochains jours des éléments très
factuels justement sur tous ces éléments
sur tous vos questionnements par rapport
au sud aussi à la fiscalité parce que
c'est ces éléments là qui vous
permettront d'être les meilleurs
ambassadeurs mais en tout cas moi je
suis persuadé qu'aujourd'hui notre
richesse de l'agriculture française
c'est aussi justement d'amener ces
éléments complémentaires à
l'alimentation sur lequel il faut pas
qu'on est de justement ni de tabou ni de
juger sur lequel on pourrait être pris à
mal mais justement des arguments de et
surtout qu'on parle de durabilité et
terminer simplement sur la décarbonation
ce qu'on veut faire sur la filière
justement agricole sur les carburants
agricoles et on aura besoin bouquet
énergétique on aura besoin de tout de
même malheureusement on n'aura pas et on
n'aura pas que les biocarburants mais de
carburant électricité hydrogène
méthanisation c'est ça qui fera la
réponse la meilleure réponse et la
meilleure réponse en termes de
compétitivité pourquoi aujourd'hui on
n'est pas parce que justement en terme
de compétitivité on sait qu'on a besoin
globalement de 100 litres pour produire
un 100 litres de carburant pour produire
un hectare de blé et quand on a besoin
de 100 litres aujourd'hui quand on avait
le GNR qui était à 50 centimes ou à 60
centimes et que le coup de production
d'un biocarburant était plutôt à 80 mais
on a aussi besoin justement de s'habiter
à réglementaire c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
voudrait bien passer au B30 mais
qu'aujourd'hui le B30 aujourd'hui on a
aussi des gens qui en face se disent bah
c'est pas forcément la volonté de tous
donc on a besoin d'écrire ensemble cette
feuille de route de décarbonation de la
filière agricole mais on doit et on y a
contribué sur la sur la feuille de route
du transport sur la feuille du route de
l'aviation on peut être solution et en
même temps les amanités POS itives de
tout ce qu'on va pouvoir la fermer
France va pouvoir contribuer c'est qu'on
va pouvoir faire des feuilles de route
pour moi en carbone positif c'est à dire
que nous par rapport à notre captation
dans les sols par rapport à la
biodiversité etc on peut amener des
choses qui sont très résilients par
rapport à tout ce qui nous est demandé
je pense qu'on a surtout besoin c'est
d'être peut-être des meilleures
communicants mais je vais surtout les
autres laisser les autres je suis désolé
je suis d'accord avec vous sur la mix
énergétique et moi il faut que je me
partage dans différentes réunions
alors change de président mais on
continue
qui sont nombreuses j'ai été sollicitée
directement
donc je
vais reprendre les réponses au fur et à
mesure déjà sur la dépendance
protéinique au niveau des matières
riches en protéines en Europe on a une
dépendance à 65%
à 65% sur les matières riches en
protéines tout à fait en France et ça a
été stipulé tout à l'heure par
Jean-Guillaume il me semble on est à 45%
. donc on a sacrément amélioré on a fait
du chemin depuis 20 ans on a quand même
fait du chemin on a amélioré notre
situation et on pourra encore
l'améliorer mais pas par une
extensification des surfaces dédiées aux
cultures la surface agricole
utile elle est bloquée elle est elle est
là elle est voire même plutôt contrainte
aujourd'hui
on pourra améliorer si on améliore
la capacité de production
c'est à dire qu'au niveau des on
travaille dans nos différentes filières
les instituts techniques notamment
terrinovia au niveau du colza
travail sur des process agronomiques sur
des parcours agronomiques qui permettent
d'optimiser la plante et l'aspect d'une
part génétique l'aspect nutritif des
plantes permet de d'optimiser les
rendements et on voit ces dernières
années avec les conditions climatiques
que l'on appelle pédoclimatique que l'on
que l'on a dans les zones de production
des rendements qui sont tout à fait
corrects ces dernières années et
en espérant que que l'on puisse
continuer à progresser donc là on aura
plus de matière et on pourra se venir on
ne se viendra pas à tous les besoins
au niveau biocarburant avec notre
filière oléagineuse par contre la
filière sera en capacité
d'aller vers le marché le plus offrant
et le meilleur aujourd'hui le prix du du
colza il est basé sur sur trois éléments
trois facteurs qui sont qui sont
extérieurs au monde agricole c'est le
prix de l'huile de palme
le cours du pétrole et puis le dernier
élément c'est le cours du tourteau de
soja
c'est ces trois composantes qui vont
nous permettre d'avoir une valorisation
de la graine
d'animer le marché et de rémunérer plus
ou moins l'exploitant agricole
voilà ça c'est globalement ça veut dire
que plus on produit le biocarburant
moins on est dépendant en matière de
Richard protéines moi on apporte de
tourteaux de soja c'est ça voilà tout à
fait on améliore la souveraineté
j'ai énergétique et alimentaire animal
Fides au niveau de
au niveau de la au niveau du territoire
que l'on prend en compte
après il y a eu une question également
sur pourquoi on ne met pas du du Besson
dans notre acteur voilà aujourd'hui on a
dans le GNR le carburant que l'on
utilise on a 7% d'incorporation
maintenant ça a été dit juste avant en
question de coût
on peut pas se permettre d'aller à 100%
on colle pas si demain le pétrole est à
200 dollars le baril
on trouvera une valorisation voilà mais
c'est pas le cas on nous l'a promis il y
a quelques années à 200 dollars le baril
aujourd'hui ils sont obligés de réduire
les productions pour pour espérer avoir
du 80 dollars voilà voilà un petit peu
le
les éléments que je vous ai je voulais
vous apporter pour pour répondre
merci président juste pour compléter sur
sur le volet du coup clairement
aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas la tire
verte il n'y aurait pas incorporation de
vos carburant puisque l'hypocarburant ne
sont pas compétitifs par rapport au
fossiles c'est parce qu'il y a une
incitation pour ce volet renouvelable
qu'on est en mesure de l'incorporer et
d'ailleurs il a fallu modifier les les
critères pour pouvoir continuer à
incorporer ces biocarbures
oui pour répondre à quelques autres
questions certaines très précises alors
pour les rendements énergétiques donc
savoir finalement pour une unité
d'énergie fossile combien on produit
d'unités de d'énergie renouvelable donc
ça il y a des ratios qui ont été
établies dans le cas notamment de
l'étude de la ADEME de 2010
mais ces ratios donc pour du bioéthanol
pour on produit deux unités d'énergie
renouvelable pour une unité d'énergie
fossile dépensée pour le fabriquer tout
au long de son voilà de son cycle de
culture et transformation donc ça c'est
pour l'éthanol mais ça peut être c'est
au moins deux voir un peu plus
pour les Estaires
pour la question sur la taxation du gaz
est-ce que le gaz du bioga soit du
biométhane serait tombera de la même
catégorie que les carburants fossiles en
fait la directive
énergies renouvelable définit ce qui est
un carburant de type de première
génération il y a une définition c'est
donc si par exemple notamment comme en
Allemagne ou le le biogaz est produit à
partir de
alors le
biométhane qui va être utilisé en dans
les comme carburant on va l'appeler du
bio GNV pour gaz naturel véhicule bio
méthane gaz naturel je sais pas comment
on dit mais voilà donc en gros c'est
quand on est GNV c'est déjà quand c'est
son petit nom pour carburant mais
le fait d'être classé dans cette
catégorie
comme les fossiles dépendra savoir si la
matière première est considérée comme
une matière qui donne des biocarbures
une première génération ou pas
en général aujourd'hui en France c'est
pas le cas puisque en France comme ça a
été dit les on utilise très peu de
culture principale on utilise
principalement des effluents des déchets
et des cultures intermédiaires donc les
cultures intermédiaires ne sont pas dans
cette dans cette définition donc les un
carburants gazeux
qui viendrait qui seraient ici de nos
donc de nos biogaz français il va
normalement n'est pas classer dans cette
catégorie
il y avait une question sur la Cour des
comptes
l'accord des comptes c'est un long
dialogue que l'on a avec elle puisque
en
2021 enfin on était au troisième rapport
de la Cour des comptes sur les
biocarburants ils vont aussi une
première fois en 2011 ou 2012 puis après
un rapport d'étape en 2016 voilà par à
peu près tous les 5 ans et en fait tous
les 5 ans on fait à peu près les mains
en réponse à l'accord des comptes donc
c'est un dialogue de sourd moi c'est ils
sont on a fait un courrier qu'on pourra
vous transmettre si vous voulez on a à
peu près 10 pages de commentaires si on
le rapport avec voilà donc ça on peut
éventuellement vous transmettre en voilà
il y a un certain nombre de
réponses actuelles qui montrent que
l'analyse de l'accordéon sur certains
points
voilà un correspond pas exactement la
réalité pour donner un exemple
elle s'est appuyée sur des évaluations
de réduction des missions de gaz à effet
de serre aux États-Unis
pour le bioéthanol et pas sur celle
qu'on peut obtenir directement sur le
site du ministère de l'écologie
évidemment aux Etats-Unis comme on
fabrique du bioéthanol avec du gaz de
schiste
on n'a pas du tout les mêmes résultats
en termes de performance que
qu'en Europe donc voilà donc ça ce type
de petites choses que l'on a
identifié qui
nuisent à l'appréciation générale après
il y a la dépense fiscale alors voilà
c'est un choix politique je crois qu'on
discutait il faut accompagner des
filières
comme ça a été dit la vue économie si on
produit chaque année
on cultive chaque année donc on investit
chaque année pour produire quelque chose
on renouvelle chaque fois en fait c'est
pas possible en tout cas les chalume
humaine alors que donc forcément il y a
un coût on peut pas le comparer à un
coût de pallier à l'extraction d'un
stock on investit chaque année les
agriculteurs dépensent pour pouvoir
produire une quantité de biomasse donc
ça rien que ça nécessite voilà de se
dire peut-être que si c'est meilleur il
faut l'accompagner pourquoi on si on
accompagne c'est les externalités
positives elles sont pas toujours bien
rémunérées donc ça fait partie un peu de
la de la question de de il y a des
surcos il y avait une entendu aussi une
remarque sur le fait que par exemple le
E85 avait une fiscalité très basse
et donc générer une dépense fiscale
importante je crois que ça a été dit
dans une de vos auditions alors déjà je
suis pas spécialiste de la fiscalité
mais il semble que normalement quand un
carburant une énergie a une catégorie
fiscale enfin une ligne fiscale un
numéro voilà c'est il a sa propre
fiscalité et le 85 a une ligne
particulière c'est la ligne de la
fiscalité du E85 donc il est pas sa
fiscalité ne peut pas être comparée
directement à celle du de l'essence
donc il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
dépenses fiscales en tout cas qui
pourraient apparaître si on voulait
aller quand même dans cette direction on
remplace quand même
avec l'électrification on remplace des
voitures sur lesquelles les carburants
sont soumis à une TICPE très élevée par
une énergie enfin un vecteur de mobilité
qui est très efficace et pour lesquelles
on consomme moins d'énergie et sur
laquelle la fiscalité est plus faible
donc là il y a une déperdition de
fiscalité énorme en passant à
l'électrification c'est un autre sujet
mais c'est voilà il faut aussi comparer
et le 85 est classé dans les catégories
des biocarburants on va dire des parents
des carburants alternatifs
comme le gaz naturel véhicule qui est
fossile et le GPL fossile qui est
l'unité d'énergie sont taxées moins
chères que le E85 donc voilà donc
si on voilà quand on parle de la
fiscalité il faut mettre tous les
aspects les aspects
bout à bout alors je sais pas si
d'autres veulent compléter sur d'autres
points
alors le prix du blé si vous voulez il a
flambé sur une sur une tellement courte
période que alors j'ai pas j'ai pas le
chiffre concret de la filière mais
l'impact de cette situation il est il ne
peut qu'être multifactorielle sur la
filière c'est à dire que le prix du blé
en effet alors ça tombe bien parce que
j'ai eu un conseil d'administration tout
à l'heure et on nous a montré
l'évolution du prix du blé qui s'est
effondré donc à ce jour on a une
cotation
inférieure à 250 euros la tonne donc
malheureusement pour nous grandculteur
nous ne sommes plus dans les le pics de
435 euros qui a eu lieu au mois de enfin
début 2022 voilà mais
au-delà de ça sur cette période
incertaine et très volatile le problème
c'était plutôt le coup d'énergie qui a
flambé dans tous les sens donc vous dire
vous répond de façon pertinente sur du
cours du blé sur la filière biocarbes
honnêtement à cet instant là c'était
aussi l'électricité c'était aussi le
c'était aussi les engrais enfin c'était
tout quoi c'était une période de très
incertaine donc je vous dirais que voilà
c'est multifactoriel et je crois pas que
c'est une grande incidence en tout cas
sur la période là et malheureusement
malheureusement le prix le prix a baissé
et malheureusement aujourd'hui on parle
plus d'effets ciseaux mais c'est pas le
sujet d'aujourd'hui mais vous parliez un
petit peu de voilà de valeur ajoutée on
est plus aujourd'hui dans un effet
ciseaux c'est à dire un prix qui est qui
colle au coût de production et voilà
l'euphorie c'est un peu éteinte
pour vous dire que malheureusement la
question est un peu théorique parce que
depuis la directive de 2015 la directive
européenne sur les changements directs
d'affectation des sols
l'incorporation de biocarburant et
plafonné à 7% en énergie et il se trouve
que la France ayant été plutôt bonne
élève de ce point de vue là et bien on y
est déjà à peu de choses près aux 7%.
donc on a ce plafond de verre et le
plafonnement à 7% ben c'est un petit peu
me semble-t-il une application du
principe de précaution où on a répondu
probablement aux critiques sur les
concurrences alimentaires dans les
commentaires mais surtout à la
problématique des changements indirects
d'affectation des sols que j'ai évoqué
dans mon intervention précédente
au-delà de ça il faut rappeler quand
même que la feuille de route entre
guillemets de nos filières avant 2015 on
a vu le convenir à partir de 2013 la
feuille de route c'était 10%
d'incorporation à l'horizon 2020
et donc on voit quand même que les
choses ont changé et il est clair que
ce cette décision de plafonner à 7% à
casser en quelque sorte la dynamique de
développement des filières et
aujourd'hui
on peut regarder d'autres d'autres voix
d'incorporation mais si vous voulez que
ce soit dans les transports routiers
l'aviation le fluvial le maritime tout
ce que vous voulez le 7% s'impose et et
pour avoir pu échanger assez
régulièrement avec des responsables de
la Commission
mon sentiment je le dis aussi clairement
que ça a clairement été que les
biocarbures de première génération la
Commission européenne leur tourne le dos
elle les a promus avec la directive de
2003 et aujourd'hui un elle n'assume pas
et alors quelle influence faut-il y voir
sa il ne m'appartient pas d'y répondre
mais il y a le constat d'une véritable
volte-face de la Commission européenne
en matière de politique de biocarburant
et de notre point de vue sans que cela
ne repose sur des faits étayés et
scientifiquement démontré et là n'est
beaucoup d'incompréhension
si le président me permet juste un
commentaire c'est pourquoi je vous
posais tout à l'heure ces questions
parce que je vais pas mettre dans ma
bouche des mots qui viendrait de la
commission mais on a quand même eu des
échanges et pas seulement avec la
Commission et effectivement il y a quand
même un sujet c'est pourquoi je me suis
permis de le poser clairement on le
redire à Stéphane de mini qui nous a
quitté là
qui parce que là il y a l'Ukraine on est
encore en 2024 2023 en dérogation mais
sinon on est sur 3% de retrait 3 à 7 %
selon les choix des agriculteurs de non
productions sur le sur les territoire
française c'est juste une aberration
alors que d'autres pays où d'autres
continents font des choix complètement à
opposer en termes de compétitivité de la
ferme France on va partir l'année
prochaine vous savez c'est comme si
producteur de n'importe quel
usine repartirait en début de l'année à
-3 ou à moins ou moins 7 points en
termes de compétitivité on a intérêt de
derrière de ramer très fortement
peut-être un mot simplement à Vincent de
nous dire la fiscalité telle qu'elle est
par rapport justement à la en lien avec
le simplement une précision sur sur une
évolution toute récente qui a fait
législateur pour justement pouvoir
comparer la fiscalité des différents
carburants et biocarburant désormais on
a une unité commune qui n'est plus comme
avant la tonne hectolitre on a le méga
water donc aujourd'hui on est capable de
voir les différencieres de taxation par
mégawater pour les différentes pour les
différentes catégories de carburant il y
a quelques exceptions près que sont le
gaz de pétrole liquéfié et les gaz
naturels de carburant qui sont des
énergies fossiles à des taux de taxation
très inférieur aux autres on a bien le
différentiel de taxation aujourd'hui
dans législation française entre des des
biocarburants donc avec des une fraction
des missions carbone inférieur au
carburant fossiles différencier le
taxation significatif un facteur 6 à
environ entre les carburants fossiles et
les carburants
et les biocarburants et simplement selon
l'a pas dit depuis le depuis le début
donc la taxation aujourd'hui sur les sur
les carburants la part majoritaire c'est
ce qu'on appelle la c'est la part
carbone donc la composante carbone qui a
fait grand bruit en 2018 sur son sur une
éventuelle trajectoire de sur une
éventuelle évolution donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la trajectoire de la de la
composante carbone
et gelée encore à ce jour mais quand
vous posez la question tout à l'heure
monsieur le Président entre une
éventuelle indexation entre la fiscalité
des produits pétroliers et des bio
carburants on n'a pas une indexation à
ce niveau là on a une indexation on a
une proportionnalité en fonction des
émissions de carbone par rapport
justement à cette composante carbone
comprise dans chaque carburant et
biocarburant de fait et ce qui explique
du coup les différents styles de
taxation initiaux qu'on avait et qui
aurait évolué de la même manière en
fonction de l'évolution programmée de la
taxe carbone enfin de la composante
carbone qui elle-même aurait amené une
évolution de de la trajectoire et donc
là en l'occurrence pour des carburants
si on prend différents sels de taxation
entre un super éthanol de 85 taxé à 17
euros environ le mégawattheure et un
Ess ence classique à 76 euros le
mégawattheure voilà on voit le facteur à
peu près 6 sur sur des sur des
carburants enfin sur un super éthanol
qui contient 85 % de carburant et donc
ce cette proportionnalité entre entre
ces deux carburants se retrouver dans la
logique même d'évolution de cette taxe
en fonction de l'évolution de la
trajectoire carbone
oui simplement je voulais revenir sur
sur un point par rapport
aux cultures intermédiaires au niveau
Europe et la réglementation européenne
nous
et françaises nous demandent de couvrir
nos sols en permanence donc on a mis en
place des cultures intermédiaires donc
c'est une contrainte réglementaire à
partir de cette contrainte réglementaire
on a essayé on essaye d'optimiser et
d'en faire une une opportunité notamment
pour pour mettre en place de nouvelles
productions où on enlève que la partie
aérienne de la plante toute la matière
organique racinaire et les étoiles qui
restent reviennent au sol et
renourissent le sol en matière organique
par contre la partie aérienne on
l'enlève et on pourrait avec soit faire
de la cameline d'autres d'autres
produits riches en huile pour pour du
jet fuel mais également on en une
destination pour la méthanisation voilà
le l'objectif il est pas de reprendre le
schéma de voisin qui aurait pu mettre
que du dédié pour des méthaniseurs et
pour faire du gaz mais il est bien
d'adjoindre une je dirais une nouvelle
destination une nouvelle valorisation
d'une nouvelle production sur les mêmes
surfaces en fait c'est faire trois
récoltes sur deux années alors c'est pas
toujours le cas partout et c'est quand
les conditions pédoplatiques le
permettent malheureusement ce n'est pas
pas le cas tous les ans
et on a
j'ai perdu le fil de mon idée mais voilà
on est vraiment en
en mixe en mix au produit on est obligé
d'avoir un mix produit sur nos
exploitations agricoles pour avoir une
résilience aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
continuer à nourrir la France et au-delà
il y a un rapport d'un vélo jeune du CGR
qui est sorti à l'autre à l'automne et
qui précise que je sais plus si c'est
2040 ou 2050 mais 50 % des revenus d'une
exploitation agricole viendront de
l'énergie quel que soit sa forme donc ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui même les
prospectives au niveau de l'État disent
attention il y a peut-être du
photovoltaïque peut-être de du gaz des
bio-carburants et ainsi de suite à faire
nous on n'est pas opposé aux autres aux
autres carburants on veut simplement
dire nous on est capable de produire
chez nous en France d'améliorer notre
souveraineté aussi de ce côté là
souveraineté alimentaire souveraineté
énergétique on peut contribuer et on
répondra à présent je vais laisser Luc
merci Claude Sud
merci
Guillaume a appris le sujet que je
voulais aborder sur les cultures
intermédiaires c'est normal mais je
voulais
voilà je voulais le poursuivre en
attirant votre attention aux étalez à
Bruxelles vous avez dû rencontrer la
Commission européenne la Commission
européenne pousse notamment beaucoup le
sujet des avancées
qui malgré les coefficients
multiplicateurs dont il bénéficient et
dont ils vont continuer à bénéficier a
priori ont du mal à se développer et
atteindre leurs objectifs mais il faut
prendre garde à ce que cet accès là ne
se conduise par accroître la dépendance
quelque part de l'Union européenne
lorsque on importe des huiles de cuisine
usagées qui éventuellement sont une
huile de palme dans lequel a été mis
d'une frite pour dire c'est en carburant
avancé avec un avantage en matière de
gaz à effet de serre quelque part ça
interroge aussi sur ce qu'est demain
pour nous la notion de renouvelable que
sera produit au sein d'Union Européenne
d'où l'intérêt pour nous aussi que les
cultures intermédiaires telles que on
les développe puisse elle aussi être
reconnue comme étant des productions
avancées puisqu'elles ne prennent
absolument pas sur le sur l'alimentaire
c'est une culture complémentaire
supplémentaire à la culture alimentaire
telle qu'elle est faite jusqu'à présent
monsieur le rapporteur
je regardais mes collègues parce que ils
peuvent réintervenir tout moment
du président l'un d'entre vous tout à
l'heure a évoqué la production de CO2 je
sais plus le pardon lequel est-ce que
vous envisagez des accords en vue
notamment de production de carburant de
synthèse peut-être qui implique donc la
combinaison d'hydrogène et de CO2
ce Chartier alors aujourd'hui on
sort du CO2 sur la méthanisation entre
autres on a du CO2 qu'on le que l'on
peut que l'on peut récupérer que l'on
pourrait réinjecter dans le méthaniseur
à différents niveaux mais aussi il y a
des process qui sont à l'étude et qui
permettraient certainement là de
d'arriver à optimiser un petit peu et de
faire de l'hydrogène vert sur sur ces
carburants de nouvelles générations
ce qu'il faut surtout me semble-t-il au
niveau législatif c'est ne pas fermer la
porte au monde agricole
ce n'est pas le monde de l'industrie et
de l'industrie
peu importe laquelle mais qui doit se
préserver après carré le monde agricole
demain aura certainement une réponse
aussi et une possibilité de fournir de
l'hydrogène vert avec
issue de pilotes et même d'installation
qui qui demain seront performantes
vous aurez peut-être l'occasion
d'interroger ou de dictionné des
industriels du secteur du bioéthanol
mais donc à chaque fois qu'on fait des
vidéos on produit forcément du CO2 de
fermentation aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
y a que 30 % de ce CO2 qui est qui est
capté donc il reste un potentiel
supplémentaire on a d'ailleurs
normalement des rendez-vous avec les la
DGAC et la DGEC sur cette Bella dans le
cadre de la mission flash
de Monsieur bonnelescure et panier
roynaché qui est en qui est en cours
mais effectivement ça fait partie des
opportunités qui pourraient être
développées mais on a vu que c'est quand
même assez compliqué enfin le procédé de
méthan-nation et ou de fabrication des
fuel pour pour avion est assez complexe
mais je crois que comme ça a été dit il
y a des
appels à projets qui ont été lancés et
donc des projets qui sont qui sont qui
vont être mis en oeuvre voilà pour
valider les technologies mais
si je pouvais me permettre
de rajouter quelque chose vous avez posé
une question tout à l'heure sur
quelques capacité à répondre à des
nouvelles opportunités donc comme le
carburant d'aviation
il faut que ça reste comme ça et dit une
possibilité c'est à dire que en termes
massif quand on dit on capte du CO2 du
bioéthanol il faut déjà avoir produit de
bioéthanol
donc si on peut pas faire enfin voilà on
est plafonné par le niveau de 7%, on
s'est compliqué de produire plus de
bioéthanol en tout cas par cette voie là
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
associer essayer d'aller trouver ces
opportunités même sur des volumes qui
sont pas forcément négligeables si je
pense à l'usine de lac de maïs
en produisant 2 millions d'hectolitres
d'éthanol mais à peu près on pourrait
avoir un potentiel de 150 000 tonnes 140
150 000 tonnes de CO2 donc c'est des
c'est des volumes massifs dont une
partie déjà captée mais je voulais
éventuellement revenir sur
cette question dessive on a beaucoup
entendu et notamment
à l'athème avec le la réflexion sur la
transition 2050 qu'on a une
problématique de bouclage des ressources
en biomasses l'ADN a résumé les choses
dans ces scénario
il faut en gros dans les différents
scénarios doublés la demande en biomasse
mais en même temps faudrait pas toucher
aux terres agricoles et il faudrait pas
toucher aux forêt
donc ils ont signalé qu'il y avait
éventuellement l'alimentation qui
pouvait évoluer
c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'il
faut probablement prendre en compte et
s'il y a des évolutions se poser la
question de savoir si l'évolution des
terres qui seraient entre guillemets
libérés du fait d'une évolution des
modes des modes alimentaires est-ce que
elles doivent aller un peu comme disait
Transport et Environnement juste pour
fabriquer de la voilà du bois de la
prairie ou être utilisé pour de la bio
économique parce qu'on a besoin aussi de
fabriquer des produits chimiques
biosourcés
et notamment par exemple la Commission
européenne dans son
projet de réglementation sur les cycles
carbone durables et notamment la
certification de la du carbone farming
donc de la capture de CO2 dans des
produits
biosourcés ça pourrait être une occasion
les Allemands travaillent beaucoup
justement sur cette chimie du CO2 donc
il faut il faudrait pas non plus par
exemple considérer que ce CO2 venant de
de l'éthanol de maïs ou de blé soit
considéré comme un CO2 de première
génération
mais pas forcément à l'abri d'une
interprétation de cette nature donc
voilà il faut aller chercher des espaces
là où ils sont peut-être que le plus
grand espace il est sur les cultures
intermédiaires il me semble que ça c'est
un point important et si je voulais
terminer par ça je pense que dans le
cadre des grands objectifs qu'on devrait
s'assigner dans le cadre de la SNBC
stratégie nationale bas carbone ou au
niveau pour remplir les objectifs
européens par exemple de ripower U qui a
doublé en 2030 les ambitions européennes
de production de biométhane par rapport
à celle par rapport aux précédentes la
France elle doit y aller
elle doit jouer ses cartes sa carte
européenne elle doit contribuer à ses
objectifs et sans les cultures
intermédiaires je pense qu'on y arrivera
pas
merci je vous pose une dernière question
à tous si demain il y avait plus de
biocarburant qu'elle serait les
conséquences sur chacune de vos filières
quelles seraient les conséquences sur
l'environnement sur l'aménagement du
territoire et
bien sûr
devenir de l'agriculture monsieur
vice-président
la première conséquence si on devait
arrêter d'incorporer c'est qu'on fait
monter en flèche les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans les transports donc
de l'ordre de 4 à 5 % instantanément
donc je veux pas vous donner les
chiffres comme ça en tonne de CO2 mais
ça va être des millions voilà donc ça
c'est une première conséquence après
clairement
on affaiblit les filières concernées
donc ça peut vouloir signifier
des arrêts de d'un certain nombre de
sites industriels implantés dans des
territoires ruraux ou il y a pas
tellement d'alternative en matière
d'emploi malheureusement
pour les agriculteurs
on peut dire toujours ils feront autre
chose mais enfin à quel prix puisque
ça veut dire que les produits que je
fais le prix de beaucoup de production
s'effondrer puisqu'on retrouve pour
moins de débouchés une disponibilité
supérieure donc baisse des prix
avec les conséquences économiques en
matière d'investissement sur
l'exploitation mais là je vais laisser
les agriculteurs répondre là dessus donc
clairement ça conduira une
déstabilisation
de l'ensemble de l'ensemble de les
filières des filières et une
fragilisation de production
qui sont on l'a dit associés en quelque
sorte à cette des biocarburant et donc
ces productions qu'on a évoqué pour
l'alimentation humaine pour
l'alimentation animale et pour beaucoup
d'autres
usages
industriels et autres
merci la FAP
alors je dirais que
l'enjeu sur la filière sur la filière il
serait significatif je n'ai pas me
risquer comme mon voisin mon
prédécesseur a donné un chiffre
qui serait de toute façon erronée
après au niveau de l'exploitant agricole
dans dans la rotation
aujourd'hui c'est le colza c'est un
million un million 3 d'hectares au
niveau national et c'est il faut pas
beaucoup plus on est déjà monté plus
haut par le passé mais on voit qu'on a
des problématiques agronomiques qui
arrivent derrière
si on réduit signifie significativement
la seule ça veut dire que sur nos
exploitations on a une rotation qui est
qui est cassée en va enlever sur une
partie des terres le colza donc ça veut
dire plus de maladies un problème de
salissement des sols plus important
une problématique de de non rupture de
de cycle de vie de prédateurs
d'insectes qui pour les pour les autres
cultures donc l'impact il serait fort
pour le monde agricole
merci de compléter
si je peux compléter avec un impact
direct en matière de biodiversité
notamment le colza en fleurs c'est
l'alimentation des abeilles à cette
période là l'année ils ont pas d'autres
c'est celle là et et j'allais poser une
question
avec abandon des objectifs de
renouvelables ou pas parce que si on
abandonne pas les objectifs de
renouvelables et que donc on doit
toujours avoir le même les mêmes
objectifs atteints il s'agit n'imagine
pas qu'on les convales les abandonner ça
veut dire une augmentation des
importations de renouvelables c'est une
question ouverte et à partir du moment
où on recule la production de colza ça
veut dire une augmentation des
importations aussi de tourteau de soja
enfin merci
leur GPB
oui très vite je vais pas reprendre tout
ce qui a été dit mais je m'inscris tout
à fait dans ce que ce qui était dit
fragilisation du système agronomique
alors je suis très déçu qu'illicitait
mon collègue l'apiculture puisque nous
en effet on profite de nos apiculteurs
locaux pour favoriser la pollinisation
de la colza donc ça c'est tout à fait
vrai et je dirais que vraiment donc on
casse cette filière on te la casserait
on casserait donc cette filière et
derrière pour nos élevages c'est le
retour aux importations de la matière
protéique
OGM ou non clairement puisqu'on pourra
pas produire plus
alors pour le pour le maïs effectivement
on aurait donc un voilà une perte
d'approvisionnement local également mais
je crois que peut-être la première
question ce serait de se dire mais si
finalement on supprime du bioéthanol ce
serait le quand même les Français qui
perdraient en premier puisque
aujourd'hui ils ont bénéficie d'un d'une
transition écologique abordable avec des
véhicules voilà qui sont qui sont
facilement
veut dire modifiable et donc voilà ce
serait les privés enfin si tout le monde
peut acheter une Tesla ok c'est très
bien mais c'est peut-être pas forcément
à la portée tout le monde et
deuxièmement peut-être pour finir
là-dessus sur une autre sur une vision
plus générale
l'Europe est dans le monde entier enfin
elle fait partie du monde et là
aujourd'hui on parle de se dire on
fermerait une usine de 500 000 tonnes de
maïs par exemple
alors qu'on produit un milliard 200
millions tonnes de maïs dans le monde
veut dire qu'est-ce qui se passerait la
question c'est que le monde lui continue
à produire continuer à se développer à
investir et finalement c'est exonère des
débats que l'on a ici notamment sur
depuis 20 ans sur les concurrences
d'usage je rappelle deux choses les
Américains affectent 40% entre 35 et 40%
de leur production de 400 millions de
maïs par an donc à peu près 140 millions
de tonnes de maïs par an pour fabriquer
du bioéthanol et bien 140 millions de
tonnes c'est plus que la production de
béton en Europe et le Brésil pendant la
crise là sur les terrains qu'on a eu en
Ukraine et bien finalement sans rien
dire aujourd'hui produit 10% de son
éthanol à partir de maïs
à partir de quasiment 10 millions de
tonnes de maïs c'est à dire quasiment
l'équivalent de la production française
et ça c'était zéro il y a 5 ans
c'est 10% allez entre 8 et 10% de la
production de maïs brésilienne qui sont
inquiète
voilà je pense que j'ai une question
pour avoir des réponses voilà merci
Pierre merci Pierre nous a posé de
questions là moi c'est claire c'est que
la ferme franche aujourd'hui n'a plus le
droit de se couper un bras ou de reculer
dire qu'on a plus le droit déjà les
faits qui serait destructeur c'est tout
l'investissement industriel qui
appartient souvent à nos coopératives à
nos dire l'effet filière qui serait
dévastateur et puis on importerait donc
que je dis et c'est vrai ce que tu
disais sur tous nos régions qu'on
accompagné nos départements qui ont
accompagner sur ne serait-ce que sur le
boîtier E85 et qui dirait demain ce que
vous allez mettre c'est plus produit ici
mais c'est et clairement tout ce qui a
été fait depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans
moi hommage à ces gens là il faut qu'on
soit au contraire on regarde dans
l'autre sens merci de la question parce
que c'est peut-être comme ça qu'on a
peut-être dû démarrer en disant
justement tous les effets les amanités
de ce que ça peut apporter tout ce qu'on
a contribué aujourd'hui notamment sur la
flotte transport et sur les dire on a
répondu notamment à la à la feuille de
route de filière transport sur la
décarbonation sur des éléments il faut
voir dans sa globalité tout ce que ça
apporte et pas simplement sur le petit
le petit vue qui pourrait simplement
amener des concurrents entre
l'alimentaire et et l'énergie
l'effet domino que ça pourrait apporter
moi je pense qu'on a on peut plus
permettre de continuer à importer à
reculer en agriculture qu'on a besoin de
l'ensemble des éléments demain et
Guillaume et d'autres l'ont dit c'est
qu'on doit s'appuyer sur la génétique
sur les itinéraires sur tous les
instituts techniques pour justement être
encore plus durable est encore plus
vertueux et nous on a besoin quoi qu'il
arrive de maintenir le moteur thermique
parce que toutes les solutions demain et
ça sera pas un une seule solution mais
ce sera un ensemble de bouquets
énergétiques et on aura besoin notamment
pour nos forts nos moissonneuses
batteuses nos débardeuses à betteraves
par rapport à tous ces éléments on aura
besoin de continuer à investir sur le
moteur thermique parce que même
hydrogène vert ou l'hydrogène tous ces
malades on aura besoin ces éléments là
et en tout cas nous on veut vraiment se
porter sur l'agriculture comme solution
par rapport à ce changement climatique
et l'agriculture par rapport à ces
attentes sociétales par rapport à
justement à ces réponses à ses attentes
environnementales sur lequel on a des
choses à apporter c'est à dire qu'en
même temps que produit et pour ça que
nous on s'inscrit en faute aussi
vis-à-vis de la commission quand on
voudrait demain mettre quelques pour
cent de terre en non-production parce
qu'il y en a d'autres qui le feront à
notre place on n'est pas dans une bulle
il y a un monde qui continue à bouger et
qui commence et en plus il y a des
attentes qui sont là et je pense que la
France doit y répondre en tout cas c'est
la position claire de de la FNSEA par
rapport à ces éléments
merci de toutes ces bonnes réponses
monsieur sénateur monsieur le sénateur
voulait question complémentaires
monsieur le rapporteur
alors un grand merci de votre
disponibilité et puis n'hésitez surtout
pas à nous renvoyer les documents
nécessaires etc chiffrer des tableaux et
autres qui sont importants pour notre
rapporteur voilà en toute
tranquillité
transparence et équité voilà merci merci
à vous